Das war's für heute.
Das war's für morgen.
Ouch.
Das war's für heute.
aus, dass die Leute, also ich sag mal die Profis in dem Gebiet, dass die Leute sich
damit richtig beschäftigen und das ordentlich machen.
Das ist das erste wovon man eigentlich so im Hinterkopf ausgeht, solange man noch nichts
anderes mitgekriegt hat.
Und jetzt ist das Problem, dass die Millionen junger Leute aufgeweckt haben und das erste
womit sie in Kontakt kommen ist, dass sie angeschissen werden, dass sie belogen werden,
beschissen werden, ihnen der größte Mist erzählt wird, dass sie nicht ernst genommen
werden, dass versucht wird alles abzutun wofür sie sich eingesetzt haben, sprich das erste
womit die Leute in Kontakt gekommen sind ist, es sackt.
Und ihr wisst wie schwerwiegend so der erste Eindruck ist oder wie schwer es ist, den ersten
Eindruck wieder wegzukriegen.
Das heißt, die haben jetzt nicht nur Millionen Leute aufgeweckt, die haben jetzt Millionen
Leute den ersten Eindruck verpasst, sie sind die größten Spasten ever und es wird alles
getan um nichts quasi das zu machen was die jungen Leute sich wünschen.
Und das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das dazu führen wird, dass das in ein paar Jahren
alles anders aussehen wird.
Und wovon ich auch ausgehe ist, dass es weiter Zuspruch geben wird für extrem, aber zumindest
nicht den etablierten Parteien, sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass zum Beispiel
die AfD jede Menge neue Wähler bekommen wird, so wie das zum Beispiel, da hat gerade auch
einer im Chat geschrieben, weil es ist einfach so, ich bin auch an sich da, da muss ich langsam
nicht mehr wundern.
Man kann sich doch nicht wundern, wo rennen denn die ganzen Leute hin, warum mag uns denn
keiner, warum wählt uns denn mehr keiner, wenn man quasi konsistent die letzten Jahre
über hinweg sich nicht mit den Sachen auseinandersetzt, die die Leute interessieren.
Also, da muss man schon nicht wundern und man darf sich nicht vormachen, dass es jetzt
irgendjemand vielleicht irgendwie besser wüsste, es ist vollkommen egal, ob es jetzt die Linken
sind, die AfD, die Grünen, wer auch immer, die wissen es auch nicht besser, die Sache
ist bloß die, dass zumindest die Leute, glaube ich, zumindest den Eindruck haben, dass sich
die etablierten Parteien noch nicht mal mehr dafür interessieren und auch noch nicht mal
mehr überhaupt zuhören wollen, was die Leute denn wirklich bewegt.
Und wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen einem, der dir zuhört und dann vielleicht nichts
macht oder einem, der von Anfang an sagt, leck mich am Arsch, es interessiert mich überhaupt
nicht, was du sagst, dann entscheidest du dich natürlich für den, der erst mal zumindest
so tut, als würde dir zuhören.
Ja, das ist, wie man geistig so abgehoben sein kann im Kopf und das auch noch verteidigt
und im Nachhinein dann sagt, im Nachhinein dann sagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, also ich
habe jetzt dafür gestimmt, aber eigentlich, eigentlich finde ich es doch kacke, aber ich
habe dafür gestimmt.
Ja, ich meine, was musst du denn für ein Spaß sein, was musst du denn für der übelste
Lappen sein, ich meine, wenn du davon überzeugt bist, ich meine, dafür sitzt du doch da letztendlich,
wenn du davon überzeugt bist, dass es Mist ist, entweder nimmst du ein bisschen Stress
auf dich und sagst, ok, ich entscheide mich jetzt gegen das, was vielleicht mein Chef
will, aber ich bin ja hier letztendlich nicht, weil ich meinen Chef zufriedenstellen soll,
sondern vielleicht, weil ich die Leute vertreten will, die mich gewählt haben, man muss ja
dich hinstellen und sagen, hä, ich bin dagegen, was einer von der CDU CSO gemacht hat, einer
hat dagegen gestimmt, oder, aber du machst einfach mit, ohne Sinn und Verstand.
Habt ihr zufällig den Ausschnitt mit Deena bei dieser einen Talkshow gesehen?
Also ich meine, es ist nicht den Teppichhändler, sondern den Minecraft Deena, der gar keinen,
nee, ich sag nicht mehr der Minecraft Deena, es ist ja der Rennfahrer Deena, ist es jetzt
ja mittlerweile, soweit ich das mitkrieg.
Muss ich grad mal Vorschau gucken, hab ich, hab ich Low Latency Stream an?
Ja, müsste ich eigentlich haben, habt ihr das gesehen, mit Deena bei einer Talkshow?
Ja, das fand ich echt gut, ähm, das, also der hat das wirklich gut gemacht, es ist nicht
einfach, sich da hinzustellen, vor allem, es ist, es ist ein Unterschied, ob du, ob man
Erfahrung hat in sowas oder nicht, ich geh mal davon aus, er hat schon ein bisschen Erfahrung
in dem Gebiet, aber ich meine, die Typen, die da gesessen haben, haben jahrelang Erfahrung
quasi vor der Kamera sitzen und öffentlich labern und dafür hat er das wirklich gut
gemacht.
Es geht bei solchen Talkshows nicht darum, ob du, ob du Recht hast oder nicht Recht hast
oder so, es geht darum, das irgendwie gut zu verkaufen und die Leute, die da gesessen
haben, hatten in der Regel eigentlich jahrelang Übungssachen gut zu verkaufen, egal wie groß
der Schwachsinn ist und, äh, letztendlich, ähm, konnte Deena da schon ordentlich punkten,
ja.
Ich glaube, die Leute haben es immer noch nicht so ganz gecheckt, vor allem auch die
Sache, die ihr erzählt habt, dass es ja jetzt schon so ist und das ist auch eine Sache,
die ich nicht verstehe, dass das, dass darüber nicht diskutiert wird, zum Beispiel, es ist
ja jetzt schon so, dass wenn ich in meinem YouTube-Video irgendwie, äh, was weiß ich,
ob es mal übertrieben zu sagen, äh, mein Nachbar spielt im Hof den Epic Sax Guy und
ich nehme gerade ein Video in meinem Garten auf, dann, ne, habe ich schon Content-ID-Probleme
und das ist ja jetzt schon eigentlich viel zu übertrieben, das ist ja, das kommt ja
auch noch dabei, es ist jetzt schon teilweise viel zu krass, aber jetzt, jetzt kommt, ja,
aber das ist egal, die tun jetzt dann quasi so, als ist das jetzt erst so, dabei ist
das schon die ganze Zeit so.
Sind alle ins Wort gefallen? Ja, gut, das, das ist, das, das ist irgendwie so sit-up
an denen, ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht warum, ähm, das, das führt weder dazu, dass
man die Leute besser von seiner Sache noch von anderen Sachen überzeugen kann, ähm,
ja, gut, ähm, jetzt aber sind wir ein bisschen abgeschweift von der ganzen Sache, ja, der
ohne Kohl, nice, ja, ähm, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich irgendwas, ähm, Chat überlesen,
das ist eigentlich aus deinem do yourself nass geworden, ähm, ich hab, ich hab das
gebaut, aber das steht immer noch rum, weil, das kann ich auch gleich, kann ich, kann ich
mal was zu sagen, ich will nämlich noch, ich würde mir gerne sowas hier kaufen, das würde
ich mir gerne kaufen, das Problem ist, das gibt's gerade nicht, das ist die gleiche Plattform,
die wir gerade haben, nur, dass die einen Vierfach PCI Express hat und, ähm, einen Vierkern,
Vierkern CPU und die aktuellen Boards, die's Firma Nast gab, hatten entweder, ähm, ne
ordentliche PCI Express Anbindung und nur zwei Kerne oder aber vier Kerne und kein ordentliches
PCI Express und das Board ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, es ist, es kostet 40 Euro mehr als die
anderen, ähm, das ist ziemlich gut, du hast Vierfach PCI Express, zweimal Onboardsata,
ähm, die man, die, die, die, die man erweitern kann, ähm, und vier, viermal PCI Express,
also kannst du mit nem, mit nem Multiplier, äh, mit nem Portmultiplier erweitern auf,
ich glaub, bis zu zehn, ähm, und, das ist eigentlich eine bessere Plattform, aber ich,
es ist, es läuft immer noch, ja. Ich hab mir übrigens bei AliExpress ein paar Startup
Portmultiplier gekauft, die sind bis heute nicht angekommen.
Hast du eigentlich wieder Kabelinternet bekommen im Juni, endlich VDSL100? Ja, ich bin über
Unity Media grad drin, aber das ist noch die alte Unity Media Leitung, ähm, ich kann,
ich, ich bin die Telekom, bin ich erst ab August los. Telekom bin ich erst ab August
los, aber ich hab's, ich hab's so gemacht, wie wir im Stream geplant haben, ähm, mein,
mein VoIP Anschluss geht zu denen hier, also sprich, das Festnetz, das geht zu denen hier,
das da, drei Euro im Monat, telefonier je nicht, geht einfach nur darum, dass man eine
Telekom-Nummer hat. Hier geht meine VoIP-Nummer von der Telekom hin und, ähm, Internet geht,
Unity Media, Internet geht komplett zu Unity Media und die haben mir auch schon zugesichert,
dass ich meinen vollwertigen IPv4 oder alternativ sogar einen vollwertigen Dual-Stack-Anschluss
behalten kann. Und wenn man das schriftlich hat, ist schon mal ganz gut, dann, wenn die
das nicht machen, dann werd ich's auf Twitter wieder monatlang durch den Dreck ziehen,
bis es, bis ich wieder hab, ey. So, und zumindest als Paket hab ich jetzt, ähm, was stimmt
überhaupt nicht? Ich hab weder das noch das da. Ja, genau, ich hab das hier mit Upload,
mit Mega-Upload, mit, ähm, Power-Upload, oder wie der Krämpel heißt. Äh, wo kommt
man das überhaupt einstellen, mit Power-Upload jetzt? Wollte ich mal zeigen, was das kostet?
Details wahrscheinlich. Mit Power-Upload, genau. Dann, wir tun mal so, als wollen wir
es bestellen. Äh, in den Wagenkorb. Also das hier ist das wichtige 50 Euro monatlich
und das stimmt, das stimmt ja auch nicht. Das ist ja auch nur schön gerechnet, ne, mit
den 50 Euro monatlich. Das sind 50 Euro monatlich für den, für den Anschluss. Dann kommen...
Hallo? Okay, was, was auch immer. Dann kommen nochmal irgendwie 2 Euro oder so dabei für
den Power-Upload. Für den Power-Upload. Dann kommen noch, ich glaub, 20 Euro dabei für
den Kabelanschluss. Also sprich, das kostet irgendwie 75 Euro oder sowas im Monat. Plus
nochmal, plus nochmal die Gebühr für VoIP bei EasyBand. Also ich bezahl irgendwie 77
Euro oder sowas im Monat. Dann habt dafür halt 140 ab und bin in die Telekom los und
einen ordentlichen Anschluss. Los, mal kurz. Schon Battlefield 5 Firestorm gespielt? Ne.
Tronker Shake. Tools Deck Lite, beste. Ja, so ne Kacke, ey. Adblock muss aus, ich hab
überhaupt keinen Adblock an. Wieso 50 Euro? Äh, weil es ab dem, ich rechne das immer
ab dem, was es dann eigentlich kostet, ne. Ich meine, das stimmt ja nicht. Das ist ja
richtig. Eigentlich bezahlt man weniger und ich bezahl jetzt auch nicht, weil ich, wie
gesagt, ich hab ja, ich hab ja geschrieben, ich will kündigen. Ähm, ich bezahl auch
das erste Jahr nicht die, äh, 50 Euro. Ähm, aber es sind ja eigentlich mehr. Der Kabelanschluss
kommt eh noch obendrauf und sowas. So. Ähm, hab ich jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen? Bevor
wir anfangen. Also ne, ich hab ja schon erzählt, was ich machen will. Ich will meinen, ich
könnte mal den Raspberry einschalten. Ich schalte mal, ich schalte mal den Raspberry
ein, dass wir gerade mal schon den. So. Dass der schon mal starten kann. Hab mittlerweile
eingesehen, dass Battle Royale nichts für mich ist. Das hab ich schon ziemlich schnell
eingesehen. Oder beziehungsweise hab ich schon relativ schnell gemerkt, dass Battle Royale
ist. Das ist nicht mein Spielmodus. Was ich interessant finde ist, hab ich eigentlich
schon ein Bild von meiner neuen Katze gezeigt. Ähm, ich, ich find ja auch, dass der Apex
Hype wieder, wieder weg ist. Aber der Apex Hype hat sich schon erledigt. Ist Hanau asozial?
Ähm, also Hanau in der Innenstadt? Ja. Dicke Katze, guck mal. Da isser. Wobei, die, das
Bild, ne? Die sieht auf dem Bild viel, viel dicker aus, als sie letztendlich ist. Da,
da sieht sie nicht so dick aus. Hier sieht sie auch nicht so dick aus. Ah. Chico. Also,
sie heißt Chico, weil der, die ehemalige Besitzerin, glaub ich, äh, ich weiß nicht.
Das ist nicht Katzor v2, das ist Venture und Katzor v3. Das hier ist die Originale. Das
ist die Originale gewesen. Das hier, meine erste Katz. Das hier ist die zweite Katz.
Und, äh, Chico ist die dritte Katz. Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen Pech mit meinen Katzen,
oder die Katzen mit mir, weil eigentlich ging's denen bei mir immer gut. Und ich glaub,
den hat's auch gefallen, aber irgendwie waren die halt alle alt und krank. Und Chico ist
ein bisschen jünger, ich hoffe, ne, Chico? Jetzt guckt sie zu, als wüsste sie, dass ich
über sie rede. Also, ich hoffe, Chico macht's ein bisschen länger. So, ähm, jetzt fangen
wir mal mit der eigentlichen Geschichte an, was wir machen wollen. Also, wie gesagt, ich,
ich, ich, ich versuche mal mit, ähm, oh, was hat denn der Raspberry für eine IP gehabt?
So. Haha! Tatsächlich. Ähm. Also, wie gesagt, außer dem Konferenzvortrag kenne ich mich
damit nicht sonderlich gut aus. Ich glaub, den Vortrag hier hab ich irgendwie geguckt.
Also, von der Idee her machen wir halt sowas hier. Wir wollen eine Tabelle haben, wo drin
steht, ob meine Raspberries an oder aus sind. Ähm, und wir wollen ein paar Grafen, also
ne, nachdem ich rausgekriegt hab, ob meine Raspberries an oder aus sind, beziehungsweise
darauf irgendwelche Services abgekackt sind oder sowas, oder wie voll die Festplatte
ist oder sowas, will ich, will ich ne Übersicht haben, ähm, host up down, und ich will ne
Übersicht haben, so nach dem Motto Festplattenplatz, so und so viel frei, so und so viel belegt
und wenn über, sag mal über 90% ist, ähm, dann solls halt rot werden oder irgendwie
sowas in der Richtung, muss ich mal genau angucken. Ähm, da guck ich da einfach abends
mal drauf oder lass mir ne Nachricht schicken, dann weiß ich. Nicht, dass das Ding wieder
kaputt ist, weil, wie gesagt, das ist, ähm, der Raspberry im Keller ist vollgelaufen,
die SD-Karte und dann ist er abgekackt. Beziehungsweise hat es nicht mehr weitergemacht und der Raspberry
im Keller ist ja eigentlich da, um historische Statistiken für, von der Heizung zu sammeln
und dann an meinen Homocysten, an meine Heimautomatisierung zu schicken und das hat er jetzt nicht gemacht.
Und das hab ich auch zu spät gesehen, jetzt hab ich irgendwie so ungefähr ne Woche keine
Statistiken und ich hätte jetzt auch nicht festgestellt, wenn die Heizung irgendein Problem
hat, weil ich mein, das ist, ähm, also, Stromverbrauch, ja, Stromverbrauch leider noch nicht. Da bin
ich grad dabei zu gucken, wie man das am besten macht und das gibt's viele Lösungen
und irgendwie gefällt mir davon nix so richtig. Ja, und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, es wird
jetzt mal eine Zeit, dass ich mitkriege, wenn meine Raspberries abkacken. Ja, wenn jetzt
zum Beispiel der, das TV hat einen, der TV-Server abkackt oder so, ist kein Problem. Das krieg
ich mit. Spätestens, wenn einer schreit, dass der Fernseher nicht geht. Aber, ob das
Ding jetzt im Keller funktioniert oder nicht, krieg ich nicht mit. Und das, das Problem
jetzt mal. Also, wir müssen übrigens gar nicht auf den Raspberry drauf. Wir machen
uns jetzt erst mal, wir machen uns jetzt erst mal einen neuen Container, wir machen uns
jetzt erst mal einen neuen Rechner oder einen neuen Container zum Testen von Prometheus
und von Grafana. Und dann basteln wir ein bisschen damit rum. Wie gesagt, ich bin da
kein Profi, was das angeht. Ich hab damit wenig gemacht. Äh, LXC Lounge, oh, wie ging
das nochmal? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken. Lounge, ich guck mal nach. Ich kann
mir das aus dem Kopf machen. So, so, genau. So, allerdings nicht, äh, nennen wir das
neueste, kommen wir dem 18.10. Obwohl, müsste, müsste nicht jetzt demnächst das neue Ubuntu
rauskommen? Also, müsste doch jetzt eigentlich soweit sein. Beta von Ubuntu veröffentlicht,
ja. Wann ist denn, das kommt wahrscheinlich Ende April oder so, müsste es, Disco Ding,
ach du Scheiße. Disco Dingo, ey. Oh Gott. Das wird auch langsam, naja, ähm, am 18.
April, okay. Okay, so geht das. Also, mal mal 18.10 und nennen das Ganze jetzt mal Container,
monitor. Warum gab es nie ein 15.10? Gab's das nicht? Also, von der Logik her müsste
es das doch eigentlich geben, oder? Wieso, gibt's doch. Oder hab ich, ich glaub, ich
hab den Gag nicht verstanden. Beta ist auf Production-Server. So, ähm, okay, ähm, jetzt
mal Lists. Äh, äh. So rum? Ah, okay. So, updaten wir den Kram erstmal und dann installieren
wir uns jetzt in den Prometheus, installieren uns in Grafana und gucken mal, was man damit
so machen kann. Erstmal den ganzen Kram updaten. Äh, Tira Fox, das verfolge ich nicht, keine
Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht, was der für Nickname hat. Äh, so, nein, die Sonoff-Dinger gibt's
nicht mit einem normalen Stecker. Die Sonoff-Dinger sind, ähm, ach ja, bekann ich euch mal was
schönes zeigen, was ich mir gekauft hab, für Heimautomatisierungszwecke. Ähm, also die
Sonoff-Dinger finde ich persönlich jetzt nicht so tolle, weil du kriegst sie nirgendwo
drunter, ähm, und sie haben keinen normalen Stecker. Ähm, was ich viel schöner finde,
ist das hier. Da hab ich mir nämlich einen 10er-Pack von bestellt. Die Dinger sind klein.
Die Dinger sind klein und passen in die Dose rein. Also sprich, was man damit machen kann,
ist, ähm, ist im Prinzip ein WLAN-Schalter. Also sprich, du kannst damit, sagen wir ganz
billig gesehen Licht an- und ausschalten, allerdings, und jetzt kommt der Witz, ähm,
du kannst damit weiterhin über den Schalter ein- und ausschalten. Also sprich, du kannst
über das WLAN ein- und ausschalten, dein Licht, und du kannst über den Schalter das
Licht, also sprich, der Schalter, der halt auf der Dose drauf ist, ein- und ausschalten.
Das ist nämlich das Problem, oder ich denke mal zumindest den Fehler, den viele machen,
wenn sie mit Heimautomatisierung anfangen. Sie fangen, äh, zum Beispiel mit Licht an,
weil Licht ist immer so, das ist so das Präsenteste und das Erste, wo du irgendwie dran denkst,
wenn es ums Thema Heimautomatisierung geht, und dann kaufen sich die Leute irgendwelche,
irgendwelchen Smart-Light-Geschichten, ja, oder kaufen sich dann irgendwelche, ähm,
irgendwelche Lichter, die dir in die Fassung drehst und die du über WLAN ein- und ausschalten
kannst. Das Problem dabei ist bloß, dass das, äh, den ersten Kontakt mit der Realität
nicht aushält, weil das Erste, was passiert ist, man drückt auf den Schalter vom Licht
und aus ist mit smarter Klübirne. Deswegen der richtige Ort, wobe sein, seine Steuerung
im Haus oder halt auch für Licht, äh, smart zu machen, ist am Schalter, zum Beispiel mit
sowas. Also sprich, dann kann ich weiterhin am Schalter ein- und ausschalten. Ich bekomme
in meinem Heimautomatisierungssystem dann auch ordentlich reported, welcher Stand der Schalter
aktuell hat und ich kann natürlich auch über WLAN ein- und ausschalten, während ich auch
am Schalter ein- und ausschalten kann. Also ich glaube, das hat man jetzt verstanden,
was ich meine. Ähm, das heißt eigentlich muss man das so machen. Oder eben halt mit
so einem Sonoff-S-Dings, oder halt mit sowas. Ne, Moment. Irgendeiner hat doch gerade S20
geschrieben, das ist doch das Falsche. Das ist das normale Sonoff. Ah, das da. Äh,
man kann es bei den Indern kaufen oder bei AliExpress. Und, äh, wie gesagt, ich finde
das die schönere Lösung für Häuser hier in Deutschland auf jeden Fall, weil das halt
in die Dose machen kannst. Ähm, man kann die Shellys flashen mit Tasmota, oder aber
man kann die Shelly-Firmware verwenden, die drauf ist. Äh, ich hab's aktuell nur an
einem Anschluss zum Testen dran und ich verwende die Firmware, die drauf ist, weil die braucht
keine Cloud, obwohl das shelly.cloudhaus ist. Es ist, das ist wieder so ein typischer Marketing-Fail,
finde ich. Eine der Hauptverkaufsargumente für dieses Produkt ist, dass es keine Cloud-Anbindung
braucht. Und was mach ich als jemand, was mach ich als den Hersteller, der quasi als
wichtigstes Feature bei einem Produkt dabei hat, es braucht keine Cloud-Anbindung, dann
mach ich shelly.cloud natürlich, was sonst, big brain, ja. Ähm, also, die Firma, die
standardmäßig drauf ist, braucht eben keine Cloud, auch wenn das so aussieht. Das ist
total bescheuert, dass die sich Cloud genannt haben. Und du kannst das ganz normal über
normale HTTP-Aufrufe ein- und ausschalten. Das ist eigentlich super einfach, ja. Warum
nicht einfach shell.ly? Das, ich glaube, so schlau sind die einfach nicht. Die hätten
nur uns fragen sollen. So. Max, hast du beruflich schon mit großen Consulting-Häusern zu tun
gehabt? Speziell IT-Consulting, waren deine Erfahrungen positiv oder negativ? Ich würde
sagen hauptsächlich negativ. Ich hab den Eindruck, dass dort viel mehr Schwätzer
sitzen als Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben von dem, was sie machen. Ähm, ja. Was nicht
heißen soll, dass es nicht die ein oder anderen fähigen Consultants gibt. Äh, wie viele
Raspberries hast du eigentlich? Ich hab im Keller einen Raspberry. Ich hab für die Gegensprechanlage
einen Raspberry. Ich hab für die, aber der ist grad nicht an. Das ist der, den ich je
zum Testen verwende. Ähm, ich hab am Eingang einen Raspberry. Also im Einsatz sind, glaub
ich, drei Zeroes. Zero W. Das war's. So viele sind das gar nicht. Man braucht ja auch nicht
so viel. Immer halt an der Stelle, wo man sich halt benötigt. Zum Beispiel der am Eingang
ist dafür da, dass er unter anderem gucken kann, ob Bluetooth-Geräte rein rausgehen aus
der Tür und sowas in der Richtung. Dann der am Eingang kann beispielsweise meinen Staubsauger
ein- und ausschalten. Also der muss immer an Stellen sein, wo sich's halt auch lohnt.
Ja, und die haben auch noch ganz andere coole Sachen. Ich werd ja noch nicht mal gesponsert
oder so von denen. Ähm, die haben alle möglichen Sachen. Wobei ich halt den Shelly One find
ich persönlich am interessantesten einfach, weil's ein WLAN-Switch ist, der halt in die
Dose reinpasst. Die haben auch noch Licht und Smart Plugs. Smart Plugs, das hört sich
an wie irgendwie so ein XXX hier. XXX, Smart Plug, Wifi, sonst was. Naja, ähm, zumindest
was sie jetzt neu haben, ist das da. Die haben neu jetzt so ein Strommessgerät. Wollte
ich mir mal angucken, ob das was taugt. Ach nee, das ist der Shelly One mit Power, nee,
das mein ich nicht. Die hatten, ich hab letztens gesehen, die haben auch ein extra Strommessgerät
jetzt. Vielleicht gibt's das noch nicht. Dann wird's das noch nicht geben. So, ähm,
okay. Updaten wir das Ganze mal. Nee, wir haben schon geupdatet. Ich find's immer geil,
wie High-Speed die Ubuntu Mirrors, ähm, wir haben sogar schon Upgrade gemacht, wie High-Speed
die Ubuntu Mirrors am Wochenende so sind. Was ist eigentlich aus deinem Twitch-Partner-Antrag
geworden? Ähm, ich hab das ausgefüllt, dann sollte ich mich verknüpfen mit YouTube und
Twitter. Und das hat nicht funktioniert, das hab ich dann drei Tage in Folge probiert,
bis ich dann rausgekriegt hab, ähm, das lag irgendwie an meiner Browser, mein Browser
Cookies oder Zeug. Hab ich alle Cookies gelöscht, hab das Ding verbunden und dann hab ich keinen
Streamer gemacht, hab keine andere abgeschickt. Ja. Ähm, achso und als smarte Steckdosen
hab ich aktuell, ja, da steht nix drauf. Wie hießen die Dinger denn? Die sind, also die
sind, die sind richtig gute Dinger. Ähm, ich, ich muss mal kurz auf dem zweiten Rechner
nachgucken in meiner Amazon-History. Wie die, nein, zweiten Rechner. Äh, kann ich's euch
jetzt nämlich sagen? Wie die Dinger hießen? Count, Orders, Steckdose. Äh. Ja, das da.
Die da, die hab ich aktuell. Wobei, äh, die jetzt anscheinend grad nicht lieferbar
ist, also ich, ich würd mir die niemals kaufen für 40 Euro, ich hab die irgendwie gekriegt
für, für irgendwie 20, 25 oder so. Ich würd mir die, ich würd mir so heimautomatisierungszeug
prinzipiell immer nur kaufen, wenn das irgendeine Aktion hat. Weil das normalerweise viel,
viel zu teuer ist, ja. Ja, die hab ich aktuell. Und das ist ganz gut, das ist erstens ne Z-Wave-Steckdose,
also sprich, äh, das erweitert das Z-Wave-Mesh-Netzwerk zum, äh, weil, weil nur Strom, also Geräte
am Strom das, das quasi relayen können. Also das sprich, das ist keine WLAN-Steckdose.
Ähm, also man sprich, man braucht auch ne Z-Wave-Stick und alles, aber vieles von meiner Heimautomatisierung
funktioniert über, über Z-Wave. Ähm, vor allem weil es halt zaubermäßig stromsparend
ist, weil wenn du beispielsweise jetzt irgendwie nen, nen, nen Temperatursensor oder sowas
draußen liegen hast, der zweimal am Tag was schickt, das ist über WLAN, hält meistens
nicht lang und die, oder vor allem auch, ähm, Open-Close-Sensor für Türen. Das sind so
Sachen, die halten als Wi-Fi-Variante meistens nicht länger als ein halbes Jahr und die
Z-Wave-Sachen gehen auch mal, halten auch mal gut und gerne zwei Jahre, wenn nicht
viel, wenn du sie nicht oft benutzt. Ja, deswegen hab ich das für die Sachen als, als Z-Wave
drinne. So, und das ist die Steckdose, die ich hab. Das ist relativ praktisch, du hast
noch zwei Anschlüsse unten dran zum Aufladen für USB. Du kannst das natürlich über, äh,
Wireless ein- und ausschalten, halt über Z-Wave, nicht über WLAN. Äh, und sie haben
ne Strommessung drinne. Also sprich, ich kann nachgucken. Das ist ja übrigens je nachdem,
wie viel man, man kann, man kann auch irgendwie die LEDs hier einstellen, wie die leuchten.
Hab ich aber nicht gemacht. Wozu? So, weil irgendjemand das von Steckdose, sag mal, ist
die Musik aus, kann das sein? So, wir sollen gleich schon mal ein anderes Album anmachen.
Aber wir haben ja noch gar nicht beangefangen, das ist schon durchgelaufen, ähm. Äh, Serious
Max, ja, das kenn ich schon. Das, äh, neue Stackoverflow-Design. Quasi der, äh, quasi
April-Scherz. Kommt das jetzt her? Geh weg. Ist der Nightbot kaputt? Kann das sein, dass
der Nightbot kaputt ist? Bot-Rip? Warum ist der Nightbot kaputt? Moment. Ich, ich werd
den Nightbot mal wieder neu dem Channel joinen lassen. Ok, ähm, ich, ich mach den Nightbot
gerade mal wieder an. Authorisieren, jawoll. Ähm, wo kann man den Nightbot nochmal joinen
lassen? Äh, hier, Dashboard. Timers. Ah, hier, hier. Join-Channel. Ok, der Nightbot
müsste wieder da sein. Ah, funktioniert wieder. Sehr schön. Ok, ähm, ich hab jetzt ganz
viel geschmetzt, aber so wirklich angefangen haben wir immer noch nicht, ne? Ok, ich hab
jetzt hier, ok, also. Neue VM ist da, ist ein Container, ich nenn's mal VM, weil's verständlicher
ist für die meisten, glaub ich. Ähm, und da installieren wir uns jetzt mal Promethor
ist drinne. So wie ich das in dem Vortrag gesehen hab, ist das total einfach. Wir gucken
erst mal, was es hier, was es hier standardmäßig im Repo gibt. Promethor ist Version 2.3.2
und da gucken wir leider nicht dieser komische Alien-Film, sondern auf GitHub. Und dann
gucken wir mal, was da die aktuelle Version ist, weil ich geh mal davon aus, die wird
einfach, ja, guck mal, 281 und hier bei Ubuntu dabei ist 231 oder so. Das heißt, die müssen
wir auf jeden Fall dazu hier runterladen. Mal gucken, ob es, ob es vielleicht offizielle
Ubuntu-Repos gibt oder sowas. Ich möchte Stackoverflow nachbauen, wie würdest du denn
da vorgehen? Ich würd erst mal den Kunden interessieren, weshalb du Stackoverflow nachbauen
willst. Und vor allem, was möchtest du besser und anders machen als Stackoverflow, weil
davon hängt's ja letztendlich auch ab, wie man's machen würde, ja. Dann willst du einfach
den Stackoverflow-Klo nachbauen zum Üben. Intern für Firma. Es gibt doch jede Menge
Knowledge-Base-Geschichten. Das gibt schon, da gibt's schon was Fertiges. 100 Pro, also
1000 Pro. Das gibt's wahrscheinlich, hab ich noch nicht geguckt, ja. Es gibt wahrscheinlich
auch irgendwelche Open Source, Knowledge-Base oder FAQ oder sonst was Systeme. Müssen wir
mal gucken, wie sich das korrekt nennt, dass man auch richtig danach suchen kann. Gibt's
bestimmt. Also ich würd das nicht selbst programmieren. Auf keinen Fall würd ich
das selbst programmieren. Aber mal angenommen, theoretisch, man müsste es selbst programmieren.
Sowas wie Stackoverflow. Das erste, was man sich fragen muss, ist, ich überleg mal so,
wie ich das machen würde. Aber angenommen, wenn jemand zu mir kommt und sagt, Max, wir
brauchen für unsere Firma intern nen Stackoverflow-Klo und wir wollen den unbedingt selbst programmieren,
wir wollen den Fertiges verwenden. Das erste, was ich dir wahrscheinlich fragen würde,
ist, für wie viele User soll das ungefähr sein? Weil wenn dann da rauskommt, so nach
dem Motto nur 5 User, dann würd ich das zwar, würd ich mal fragen, seid ihr euch wirklich
sicher, dass ihr sowas braucht? Aber wenn sie sagen, ja, dann wüsste ich schon mal,
man muss keine allzu großen Geschütze auffahren. Und ich geh mal davon aus, dass auch die User-Anzahl
intern in der Firma nicht sonderlich groß sein wird. Aber das Wichtigste ist, wie viele
User das hat, und vor allem, womit man so ungefähr rechnet, wie viele User das gleichzeitig
verwenden. Stackoverflow hat natürlich ein bisschen mehr. Ja, ich hab nen Discord, aber
immer noch keinen öffentlichen Discord. Und ansonsten ist sowas wie Stackoverflow, glaube
ich, intern relativ simpel. Ich mein, du hast quasi ne, das ist so der klassische Fall von
dem, was du in so ner relationalen Datenbank machst. Du hast Posts, du hast Antworten auf
die Post, du hast Scores auf die Post, jeder Post hat nen User, nen User hat mehrere Posts.
Also, im Kern, würd ich sagen, ist das nicht sonderlich kompliziert und sollte mit jedem
0815 Web-Framework möglich sein, sowas zu basteln, was aussieht und funktioniert wie
Stackoverflow. Kompliziert wirds dann halt nur, wenn du noch so ein paar Spezialitäten
hast, wie zum Beispiel hunderttausende Benutzer oder sowas. Da würd ich mir da schon eher
Gedanken machen. Aber so rein vom Prinzip her ist, glaube ich, Stackoverflow-Klon zu
bauen, der einfach nur ähnlich aussieht wie Stackoverflow und so die grundsätzlichen
Funktionen hat, nicht sonderlich schwierig. Und sollte mit jedem Web-Framework, mit jeder
Datenbank funktionieren. Sogar mit sqlite sollte das ohne Probleme funktionieren. Ja.
Falls ich was übersehen hab, schreibts einfach nochmal. Mit add, add Wobblers. Okay, also
installieren wir jetzt mal hier erstmal Prometheus. Gibt es dann Prometheus Abt-Repo für Ubuntu
oder muss man da einfach das Binary draufziehen? Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Repo ist,
aber ich füge garantiert nicht dieses Repo bei mir hinzu. Es sei denn, es steht irgendwo
auf der offiziellen Prometheus Seite. Also, das nochmal ganz im Ernst. Also wer sowas
hier macht, ich sag gar nicht mal, dass das gefährlich ist, was da drin steht. Ich weiß
nicht, was das für ein Dude ist, aber ich würd nie, weil das hebt die Sicherheit vom
ganzen Paketmanager aus, ich würd niemals einfach irgendwelche Dinge adden, die in einem
Tutorial drinstehen. Das ist MonkaS extrem. Also da bist du ganz schnell am Arsch. Okay,
anscheinend gibt es kein Abt-Repo. Dann laden wir uns das einfach mal runter. Also Prometheus
für IGiD, Windows, noch schlimmer Mac OS. Warum heißt, ich weiß, dass der interne Name
von Mac OS Darwin ist, aber warum? Warum eigentlich? Also ich weiß, dass irgendwie unter Mac OS
diese Next Step, aber warum heißt das eigentlich Darwin? Hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber
gemacht. Wegen Darwin Kernel, ja klar, aber warum heißt der Kernel Darwin? Ja, das ist
mir schon klar, dass das deswegen so heißt, das Paket. Aber warum hat das Apple so genannt?
Warum Windows? Windows heißt, kann man sich vorstellen, warum Linux? Linux heißt, weiß
man auch, aber warum heißt Mac OS Darwin? Beziehungsweise warum heißt der Kernel von
Mac OS? Warum haben die das? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Warum startest du
Prometheus nicht im Docker, um erstmal rumzuspielen? Weiß nicht. Ich gucke mir, wie einfach so
was auch zu installieren ist und ich glaube bei Prometheus ist es wirklich einfach. Weil
so wie ich das in dem Vortrag gesehen habe, bläht man sich das einfach runter und startet
das und dann geht's. Oh, GitHub ist wieder wahnsinnig schnell heute. Ich bin super Technik
Noob und habe eine Frage. Ist es möglich, ein Armband, was den Puls misst, mit YouTube
oder ähnlichem zu koppeln, so dass das abgespielte Stopp mal eingeschlafen wird? Ja, prinzipiell
schon. Die Frage, die man sich generell stellen muss, das spielt schon ein bisschen in Richtung
Heimautomatisierung. Das ist ein ähnlicher Punkt, den du hast, nach dem Motto, du möchtest
zum Beispiel, dass du früher geweckt wirst, wenn dein Zug Verspätung hat. Oder, nee,
später geweckt wirst, wenn dein Zug Verspätung hat oder so was. Also, diese Automation-Geschichte
ist ja quasi ein zentraler Punkt von Heimautomatisierung. Zum Beispiel, du legst dich ins Bett und hast
vergessen, den Fernseher auszumachen und das Ding soll erkennen, ob du im Bett liegst
und dann sollst du ihn entfernen. Das ist ja was Ähnliches, was du mit deiner Uhr willst.
Also prinzipiell geht das. Die Sache, die man sich fragen muss, ist nur, wie kannst
du der Uhr entlocken, wie dein Puls ist. Also sprich, hat die Uhr in irgendeiner Form
eine Schnittstelle, wie du das abfragen kannst. Oftmals muss man da sehr trickreich sein,
weil viele Hersteller gar keinen Bock haben, diese Information raus zu rücken, höchstens
über ihre offizielle Plattform. Hab ich euch deshalb mal ein Blutdruckmessgerät erzählt,
was der Hersteller erzählt hat, mit Datenimport, wo wir gerade mal dabei sind. Ein Doktor hat
vor ein paar Jahren oder so gesagt, ich soll mir mal ein ordentliches Blutdruckmessgerät
kaufen, weil er konnte mir nicht glauben. Also ihr wisst, ich bin nicht der Allerschlangste
und ich war mal da und hab Blut abgenommen und alles mögliche und das Hammer hat er
untersucht, hat gemeint, das ist alles super und er hätte es gar nicht gedacht, dass er
so toll ist, aber Blutdruck müsste man mal beobachten und gucken und ich soll mir mal
ein gescheites Blutdruckmessgerät kaufen und da hab ich mir eins geholt und zwar ein,
ach du Scheiße, ich muss das mal raus und das Ding sieht übelst abgedreht aus schon,
oder was heißt übelst abgedreht halt. Gerade mal auf Amazon gucken. Ich glaube, ich hab
seit Jahren nichts mehr im richtigen Geschäft gekauft. Hallo Amazon, eben ging's doch noch.
Boah da ist es. So und, ah das da, genau. Das Teil hab ich mir gekauft. So und ich weiß,
es ist ein bisschen größerer Bogen Richtung Uhr oder so, aber da kommen wir gleich zu,
Uhr und Puls und ich hab mir das Ding gekauft, das ist richtig gut, das kannst du per Bluetooth
verbinden mit deinem Smartphone und kannst dann auf dein Smartphone deine Blutdruckergebnisse
sünken und das heißt, du kannst auch dann Statistiken machen und ja und irgendwann
hab ich mir gedacht, ok, es wäre doch mal nicht schlecht, dass man das, ob man, kann
man die Daten nicht irgendwie exportieren und da hab ich festgestellt, ok, das Ding
unterstützt plus Excel Format. Ah na gut, besser als nix. Zumindest ist dann irgendwann
mein iPhone kaputt gegangen und bei Bluetooth ist es ja so, wenn du Bluetooth Geräte koppelst,
dann merken die sich die ID voneinander und zumindest dieses Blutdruckmessgerät hat sich
auch die ID von meinem iPhone gemerkt. Mein iPhone ist kaputt gegangen, ich hab ein neues
iPhone und dann wollte ich das koppeln, wieder, da hat es mir beim Koppeln schon gesagt,
sie sind bereits verbunden, wo muss ich das mal vorstellen, also das alte iPhone war kaputt,
das ging nicht mehr, der Homebutton war kaputt, du konntest nicht mehr machen, außerdem hatte
ich es auch schon gar nicht mehr und da wollte ich das neue iPhone koppeln mit dem Ding und
da sagt das Ding beim Koppeln erstmal, koppeln ist nicht möglich, sie sind schon mit einem
iPhone verbunden, ich weiß aber, das ist kaputt und jetzt, ah ok, hab ich den Support gefragt
von denen, er sagt, Jungs, ich hab ein iPhone gekoppelt, das ist kaputt, ich will jetzt
mein neues iPhone koppeln, weil warum soll ich das alte iPhone gekoppelt lassen, wenn
ich das zünden will, dann haben sie gesagt, ah ist kein Problem, sie können das einfach
überschreiben, also sprich, du kannst in der App irgendwie anklicken, so nach dem Motto
ignoriere Fehler oder sowas in der Richtung, angeklickt, gekoppelt, hat funktioniert, hat
gesyncht und danach hab ich festgestellt, also hab ich den Test gemessen und so hat alles
funktioniert, er hat auch auf dem Smartphone angezeigt, also sprich, man kann das Smartphone
dann auch nachgucken, quasi die letzten Werte so und mit Kalender und Entwicklung und blah
und so, egal, zumindest wollte ich das, wollte ich dann mal nachgucken, so nach dem Motto,
wir waren an den letzten Werten, hab ich festgestellt, dieses Gerät hat nur die neuen Sachen gesyncht,
es hat nicht die alten Sachen gesyncht von vorher, also sprich, es hat nur die Sachen
gesyncht, die ich jetzt gemacht hab und nicht die, die ich schon auf mein altes iPhone mal
gesyncht hab und auf dem Gerät selbst kannst du hier die History durchklicken, hat so ein
History-Button, da sieht man die alten Werte noch, also mal wieder Support gefragt, da hat
der Support gemeint, ah okay, das ist Absicht, das ist Absicht, weil Datenschutz, also ich
sag Moment, Datenschutz, das ist mein Blutdruckmessgerät, ich sitze da vor, ich kann auf den Knopf
drücken und ich will das jetzt auf mein iPhone übertragen, was hat das denn jetzt mit Datenschutz
zu tun, das konnte er mir auch nicht so genau erklären, aber wisst ihr, was der Tipp war,
wie man das nach Abhilfe schaffen kann, er hat gesagt, ja, was ich machen könnte ist,
ich könnte mich ja mit ihrer Cloud verbinden, ich sag Moment, also, nur mal, dass ich das
richtig verstehe, es ist datenschutzmäßig bedenklich, wenn ich von meinem eigenen Blutdruckmessgerät
die Sachen über mein eigenes Bluetooth auf mein eigenes iPhone übertragen will, aber
die Sachen zu sünken in die Omron Cloud, um sie dann wieder auf mein iPhone zurück zu
sünken, das ist datenschutztechnisch nicht bedenklich und da hat er gesagt, ja, er gibt
das an das Entwicklerteam weiter und ich soll mal Adresse, E-Mail Adresse, aber ich hab
bis heute von denen nix gehört und da hab ich mir gedacht, der könnte mich am Arsch lecken,
genau, Mr.Wiltschmann, warum braucht ein Blutdruckmessgerät keine Cloud, ich weiß
es nicht, warum ein Blutdruckmessgerät eine Cloud braucht, keine Ahnung, so und da sind
wir wieder beim Thema mit der Uhr- und Impulsmessgerät, viele Hersteller haben überhaupt kein Interesse
dran, dass man die Daten aus ihren Geräten rauskriegt, ich bin der Ansicht, dass eigentlich,
ich mein, wir haben es jetzt geschafft, dass die Ladegeräte halbwegs einheitlich sind,
zum Beispiel ein sinnvolles Gesetz, was man mal verabschieden könnte ist, dass es zum
Beispiel Pflicht ist, dass man quasi Daten, die in Geräten gespeichert sind, über mich
in einem allgemein gültigen, lesebaren Format exportieren können muss, das wäre zum Beispiel
mal eine Sache, die würde ich für sehr sinnvoll halten, weil in den letzten Jahren gibt's
ja immer mehr den Trend, dass Hersteller quasi die Sachen noch mehr abschotten und
noch dichter machen, dass du an deine eigenen Sachen überhaupt nicht mehr dran kommst,
so und zu der Puls-Uhr, ich weiß ja nicht, was das für eine Uhr ist, aber es könnte
sein, dass die was anbieten, dass man den Puls auslesen kann, über irgendeine Schnittstelle,
es könnte auch sein, dass die Uhr die Daten an irgendetwas übertragen kann, so und man
muss da teilweise schon sehr erfinderisch sein, um an Daten dran zu kommen, zum Beispiel
ich möchte auf meinem Shield-TV, das Shield-TV ist ein Android drunter, also das ist nicht
so geschlossen, wie sie es gerne hätten glaube ich, zum Beispiel möchte ich auf meinem
Fernseher anzeigen, wenn das Hof-Tor auf und zu geht, wo wir wieder beim Thema Heim-Automatisierung
sind, so und das ist viel, viel komplizierter, als man sich das vorstellt, als erstes braucht
man erstmal, braucht man eine App, braucht man Notifications for Android-TV, braucht
man erstmal, das kann man so Pop-ups anzeigen auf dem Bildschirm, alternativ kann man auch
mit Tasker rum basteln, da muss man sich Tasker drauf kopieren, auf das Shield-TV, eine Maus
anschließen, weil sich Tasker nur ordentlich per Touch bzw. Maus bedienen lässt, also nicht
über die Shield-Fernbedienung und ja, zumindest braucht man erstmal einen Addon, was man anzeigen
lassen kann, und jetzt kommt der große Nachpunkt, wie kriege ich Notifications auf meinem Shield-TV
drauf, ich kriege in meinem Heim-Automatisierungssystem die Nachricht vom Sensor am Tor, dass das
Hof-Tor aufgemacht wird, wie kriege ich das jetzt auf Shield-TV und die einzige wirklich
sinnvolle Möglichkeit, die gut funktioniert, die ich gefunden habe, ist mit, wie hieß das,
Thermux, das ist ein Terminal für Android, ja genau das hier, das da, ich hab mir Thermux
installiert auf dem Shield-TV, auf Thermux habe ich per Python einen Web-Server aufgemacht
und auf diesen Web-Server schicke ich dann einen Post von meinem Heim-Automatisierungssystem,
dass das Hof-Tor aufgegangen ist und das Python-Script selber ruft dann wiederum Notifications
for Android auf, auf Localhost und übergibt ihm eine Nachricht und dass das Ganze funktioniert,
musste ich mir die Notifications for Android API aus irgendeinem Go-Programm Quelltext
auf GitHub raussuchen, voll für den Arsch, ich will einfach nur das auf meinem Fernseher
aufbloppt, Hof-Tor wurde aufgemacht, also das meine ich, man muss da manchmal sehr erfinderisch
sein, dass der ganze Grabs funktioniert, aber das funktioniert ausgesprochen gut, da hab
ich gleichzeitig noch eingebaut, dass es beispielsweise, wenn das Telefon klingelt,
gleichzeitig Kodi anhält und anzeigt, was es für einen Anrufer ist, wenn man den ganzen
kennt, das ist übrigens sehr praktisch und hat auch schon für viel Verwunderung gesorgt,
bei den Leuten, die öfters hier Fernseher benutzen, benutzen Fernseher relativ selten,
dass wenn man jetzt, das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Automatisierung, da könnt ihr
auch eure Frau, Freundin, generell alle Mädels begeistern mit solchen sinnvollen Automatisierungen,
weil die meisten Mädels sagen ja bei solchen, wenn man rumbastelt zu Hause, so nach dem
Motto, da steht wieder eine Fritzbox oder muss das Kabel denn da sein oder warum sieht
man das Gerät überhaupt im Schrank stehen, aber sinnvolle Automatisierungen gewinnen
dann quasi so überzeugen und zum Beispiel, wenn man ans Telefon geht und das Heimautomatisierungssystem
automatisch den Film anhalten kann, also einblendet auf dem Monitor, es ruft gerade, keine Ahnung,
die Werkstatt ruft an, weil das Auto fertig ist, der Opa ruft an, steht dann auf dem Bildschirm
und dann macht er automatisch für dich Pause im Film und wenn du dich hingesetzt hast und
aufgelegt hast und du wieder im Wohnzimmer bist, dann macht es automatisch den Film wieder
an ein paar Sekunden, nachdem du aufgelegt hast, aber das sind so Automatisierungen,
die sind sinnvoll, die gewinnen die Leute, die überzeugen die Leute dann auch, das ist
schon ganz cool.
Das ist nicht einfach, die Sachen immer auf dieses Thema so drauf zu kriegen, warum jemand
beeindruckt, wenn man keinen hat, weil man sich selbst vielleicht darüber freut, das
wichtigste ist ja prinzipiell, dass man mit sich selbst zufrieden ist, das kann man eigentlich
nicht oft genug sagen und wenn es was ist, was dir selber Spaß macht, ist die Sache schon
mal nicht umsonst.
Es geht gerade um Heimatautomatisierungen.
Nutzt du smarte Steckdosen?
Ja, mache ich, habe ich gerade einen Freund gezeigt, welchen ich verwende, die hier,
bloß nur kaufen, wenn sie im Angebot ist oder irgendeine andere beliebige C-Wave Steckdose,
die kann dann auch Strom messen und so.
Ja, um jetzt mal zurückzukommen zur PULS-Armbanduhr, ist derjenige überhaupt noch da, der das
wissen wollte, nachdem ich jetzt 3 Stunden drüber gelabert habe, über Prinz, so Sachen
drumherum.
Broke das ein bisschen, wir haben eine Webseite geöffnet, nein, nein, wir haben schon Prometos
runtergeladen.
Ist derjenige noch da, der das mit der PULS-Uhr wissen wollte?
Willes, es kommt halt drauf an, ob die Uhr den jetzt irgendwie mitteilt und was ich halt
mit der ganzen Ausführung jetzt erzählen wollte, ist, es ist oftmals ziemlich schwierig
und man muss sehr erfinderisch sein, Daten von einem Gerät runterzukriegen.
Wenn die PULS-Uhr eine AP anbietet, dass man das abfragen kann, wunderbar.
Man könnte sich ja auch überlegen, ob man nicht vielleicht dort was drauf installieren
kann, wenn es ein Android ist, was regelmäßig die neuen Werte pusht.
Das ist bei Android viel, viel einfacher als bei iOS.
Bei iOS ist sowas gar nicht möglich.
Erstens ist es unter iOS saumäßig schwierig, von einer App auf die Sachen von der anderen
App zuzugreifen und was bei iOS prinzipiell ausgeschlossen ist, das ist Policy von Apple,
das geht nicht.
Egal, wer behauptet, dass es geht und wer rumtricks, das geht nicht.
Dass du Anwendungen im Hintergrund laufen lasst, das sieht nur gefaked so aus bei manchen
Anwendungen als würde es funktionieren, aber du kannst keine Anwendungen permanent im Hintergrund
laufen lassen.
Bei Anwendungen, wo das funktioniert, ich glaube das einzige, was erlaubt ist, ist Musik
abzuspielen, allerdings dann auch nicht über deine Anwendung, sondern nur, wenn du das
an das Apple eigene Musikplay-System quasi abgibst, weil deine App läuft ja gar nicht
mehr.
Aber bei Apple ist es so, dass, glaube ich, du nur 10 Sekunden alle 5 Minuten irgendwie
CPU-Zeit kriegst, also du kannst deine Anwendung anmelden zu, hallo Apple, ich möchte im Hintergrund
laufen und damit ist nicht gemeint, deine Anwendung läuft im Hintergrund, sondern sie
wird alle 10 Sekunden lang, kriegt sie Zeit, ich glaube, alle 5 Minuten oder alle 2 Minuten
oder so.
Das sieht man nämlich auch, wenn man zum Beispiel irgendwelche Sachen aufruft auf seinem iPhone
oder irgendwelche Sachen anpingt, das geht dann immer mal 10 Sekunden, dann geht es wieder
3 Minuten nicht und so was.
Zumindest ist es nicht möglich, dass man eine Anwendung im Hintergrund laufen lässt
unter iOS, das funktioniert nicht.
Dementsprechend kann man da auch nicht irgendwelche Automatisierungs-Sachen machen, die permanent
im Hintergrund gucken, das klappt nicht, das geht unter iOS einfach nicht.
Dementsprechend kannst du auch auf iOS nicht drauf reagieren, wenn jemand auf deine Klingel
drückt unten und dir dann eine Benachrichtigung schickt an irgendeinem Programm, das geht
nicht, weil iOS darf nichts im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich glaube, 10 Minuten darf fast maximal im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich glaube, nach 10 Minuten wirst du hart abgeschossen und dann darfst du nur starten
per User-Interaktion.
Du musst bei Apple prinzipiell alles per User-Aktion auslösen, also sprich, deswegen kannst
du iOS auch so schlecht automatisieren.
Apple hat als Policy, du musst User-Aktion, also sprich, wenn du, du kannst, weil es hat
gerade eine Push-Nachricht geschrieben, ja das geht, aber der User muss auf die Nachricht
draufklicken.
Ja, und das kommt auch noch dazu, dass du das über Apple verschicken musst, ja klar,
der User muss auf die Nachricht draufklicken, du kannst zum Beispiel eine Callback-Uhr schicken
per Push-Nachricht, die VLC aufmacht.
Also, mal angenommen, es klingelt einer unten an der Tür, ja, und die Kamera hat einen
Livestream, die Klingel hat eine Kamera mit einem Livestream, dann könnte ich das so einrichten,
dass ich an mein iOS-Gerät eine Push-Nachricht schicke mit einem Callback-Link, ein Callback-Link,
so nennt sich das bei iOS, wo du quasi andere Programme aufrufen kannst, das heißt Callback-Link,
warum auch immer, da schickst du per Push-Nachricht einen Callback-Link an deinen User und wenn
der User, nur wenn der User draufklickt, der User muss draufklicken, sonst funktioniert
es jetzt unter iOS nicht, unter Android ist das alles kein Problem, draufklickst, dann
geht VLC auf und du übergibst ihm halt die richtige Uhr und dann macht VLC den Stream
von deiner Klingel auf und dazu, das ist auch der Punkt, wo man wieder sieht, für was die
unterschiedlichen Geräte gut sind, für alles, wo es irgendwie darum geht, was automatisch
zu machen, ist iOS nicht zu gebrauchen, kannst du einfach komplett knicken.
Das Gute ist, die meisten Leute möchten ja gar nichts automatisieren, die meisten Leute
möchten es ja einfach nur benutzen, aber zum Beispiel, ich habe hier im Flur zwei Android-Tablets
als Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard hängen, wo man dann so was, also den aktuellen Status
sehen kann, beispielsweise auslösen kann, irgendwelche Lichter oder Rollladen oder sowas
kann man damit auslösen.
MDDoctorHot, ich finde das Konzept an sich so rein aus Usersicht, finde ich es auch gar
nicht schlecht für diejenigen, die es einfach nur benutzen wollen, für alle, die damit
mehr machen wollen und nicht können, finde ich halt kacke, das Konzept, und diese Tablets
könnte ich beispielsweise gar nicht verwenden mit iOS, geht nicht, weil ich nichts darauf
automatisch aufmachen kann, nichts automatisch laufen lassen kann, nichts, deswegen müssen
es Android-Tablets sein.
Triborn, es gibt Workflows, die heißen jetzt nicht mehr Workflows, ich habe vergessen,
wie sie heißen auf iOS, das ist aber auch das gleiche, nur per User-Aktion, nur per
User-Aktion-Dinger starten, du kannst sie zwar verknüpfen, shortcuts, genau, du kannst
das Zeug zwar verknüpfen und alles machen, aber du kannst das nur per User-Aktion starten,
und wenn du in Workflows oder in Shortcuts eine Endlosschleife machst, dann läuft die
maximal 5 oder 10 Minuten, ich glaube 10 Minuten im Hintergrund, maximal, danach wird sie hart
abgeschossen von iOS, du darfst es nicht länger benutzen, und danach kannst du es nur durch
neue User-Aktionen wieder starten, aber ich muss dazu sagen, das sind nur meine Erfahrungen,
die ich bisher mit iOS und iOS-Programmen gesammelt habe, ich habe da jetzt auch noch nicht so
viel gemacht, und ich bin auch bei aktuellen Entwicklungen nicht auf dem Laufenden, was
denn danach kommt, ich finde es ein bisschen schade, dass die WebRTC-Unterstützung so grottenschlecht
ist in Headless, wie nennt sich das jetzt neuerdings, Progressive Web Apps, der funktioniert
nämlich unter iOS auch nicht so richtig gut, aber wir sind aber ganz abgeschwifft vom Thema,
also mit der Pulsur wahrscheinlich wird es funktionieren, aber es braucht ein bisschen
gebastelt.
So, ok, also jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema, wir haben Prometheus runtergeladen,
wir entpacken das ganze mal, weil das eigentliche Ziel heute ist ja immer noch, dass wir unsere
Raspberries und den Plattenplatz und sowas überwachen können, wir starten das mal und
gucken, wir starten das mal und gucken, wo es läuft, es läuft auf Port 9090, was ist
die IP von dem Ding hier, das da, 9090, bäm, läuft, also ich meine die Installation einfacher
könnte es ja im Endeffekt nicht sein, einfacher könnte es ja im Prinzip nicht sein, Prometheus
runterladen, Prometheus starten und funktioniert.
So, wie gesagt, ich hab ja auch nur ne Konferenz-Talk gesehen da zu dem Thema, so jetzt kann man
sich hier irgendwie Sachen auslesen lassen, die Prometheus einsammelt, zum Beispiel ob
es ab ist, es ist ab, wer hätte das gedacht, ich meine das läuft ja hier auch und wenn
ich den Typ auf der, in dem Konferenz-Talk richtig verstanden hab, benutzt man dieses
Prometheus-Web-Frontend eigentlich gar nicht, das ist nur zum gucken, ob es funktioniert
und zu schauen, ob beispielsweise irgendwie was rumbackt.
Wenn man wirklich ein ordentliches Frontend haben will, dann soll man Grafana verwenden,
hat er erzählt, das machen wir jetzt einfach mal, wir gucken noch mal, ob es Grafana im
Repo gibt, gibt es nicht, dann starten wir hier oben noch mal Prometheus und Grafana
abt.
Wie findest du eigentlich Docker, wenn man es für das benutzt, wofür es gedacht ist,
nämlich um Entwicklern das Leben leichter zu machen, ist das eine super Geschichte.
Ah ja, guck mal, Grafana hat ein eigenes Repo, ein eigenes Ab-Repo, das ist schön, das verwenden
wir gleich mal.
Was ist das für eine Konsole, meinst du das Programm hier oder meinst du die Shell oder
meinst, was genau, ich hab den Key nicht importiert, Reep-Streamer, ne, aber nachdem ich ja auch
ab und zu mal die Weeps erfreuen muss, hab ich die passenden Emotes am Start.
Warum hab ich 160 Zuschauer, wenn ich einfach nur in der Konsole rumklicke, sehr schön,
ja, für alle die Neuen dabei sind, willkommen im Stream, ich hab jetzt seit 3 Monaten und
so nicht mehr gestreamt, das heißt, ihr habt mich zwar verpasst, aber schön, dass ihr
da seid.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr irgendwelche Fragen übersehen habt, der sieht nicht so aus.
Achso, du nutzt Arch mit welchem WM, das ist Polybar, nein, wieder noch, das ist Manjaro,
das ist im Endeffekt, ist das Arch Linux, ja, das ist Manjaro, die haben eigene Repos,
das ist E3, E3 Gaps ist das und das oben ist keine Polybar, das oben ist E3, Moment, muss
noch kurz gucken, wie das genau hieß, ja, E3 Status Rust ist das oben, das Programm,
das ist GNOME Terminal, da drin läuft ein TMAX, da drin läuft eine ZSH und die Schriftart
ist, das Farbschema ist Base 16 Tomorrow Night 256, sowohl für das Terminal als auch
für die Shell und die Schriftart ist Hack, Schriftgröße 16.
Was hältst du denn von LPE, ist das denn nicht LPIC, Zertifizierung, lohnt sich das, kann
ich nichts zu sagen, habe ich nicht gemacht, habe ich mich nicht weiter mit beschäftigt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich, ich, also generell zur Zertifizierung bin ich kein großartiger Fan.
So, jetzt haben wir den Kram installiert, was wollen wir Krafana installieren, Krafana
haben wir auch gestartet, jetzt müssten wir noch irgendwas machen, not starting on installation,
naja, komm, wir führen das einfach mal aus, Tudu können wir uns zwar schenken, weil wir
sind schon gut, Krafana gestartet, that's that, wo läuft's, da, port 3000, also das da, port
3000, und da können wir ein paar schöne Grafen malen, oh, Username, Passwort, äh, Krafana,
Default Passwort, was ist das, Default Passwort von Krafana, Admin, Default Passwort ist Admin,
ah ja, sehr schön, Admin, Admin, safe, oh, nee, Moment, ah nee, change Passwort, 1,3,4,5,6,
bam, beste, ok, add data source, da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie unsere Prometheus Instanz
hinzufügen, da kann ich mich dran erinnern, das hat er nämlich in dem Video auch gezeigt,
Prometheus, localhost, das läuft ja alles auf dem gleichen Ding, was noch immer das
ist, ich, ich, ich ändere mal einfach nix dran, ich sag einfach mal save, ok, funktioniert,
weg, weg, Dashboard, ah ja, new Dashboard, ok, das war's schon, das ist echt simpel,
das ist wirklich simpel, ich mein einfach den Kram mit Binary runterladen, Binary starten,
dann abdrehen, hinzufügen, installieren und es läuft, also da bin ich schon mal begeistert,
viel besser als Zabbix zu installieren, Zabbix, wobei Zabbix installieren ist, ist auch nicht
schwierig mittlerweile, aber Zabbix zu konfigurieren ist eklig, hat irgend, hat eigentlich irgendwer
was von Division 2 mitbekommen, das kam noch raus, der Ehe spielt das wohl rauf und runter,
ich hab aber sonst nichts mitgekriegt zu dem Game und was für ein OS ist das, das war
Manjaro, Manjaro Linux und, ich weiß nicht was, ich find das, ich find das eigentlich
ganz cool, mittlerweile ist Manjaro zur beliebtesten, zur beliebtesten Linux Distribution aufgestiegen,
also für, ja für den Desktop Bereich, ja, was ich richtig cool finde, denn das ist die
erste Desktop Distribution, wo ich wirklich rundum zufrieden mit bin, ich hab vieles toll
ausprobiert, ja, also im Prinzip fast alles, was hier irgendwie unter den ersten paar steht,
Elemento hab ich ausprobiert, Minda hab ich ausprobiert, Ubuntu, Debian, Fedora, Asusi
irgendwann mal vor 10 Jahren oder so, ich hab alle mögliche ausprobiert und vor ein paar
Jahren bin ich auf Manjaro gekommen, da war das noch nicht so beliebt, da war das irgendwo
hier unten oder so, das ist die erste Desktop Distribution Linux, wo ich wirklich richtig
komplett, komplett zufrieden bin mit, ja, wahrscheinlich weil man eben alles selbst
machen kann, und deswegen find ichs cool, dass die jetzt auf Platz 1 sind, also sprich
Qualität setzt sich an manchen Stellen doch noch durch, hast du das als zweites OS auf
dem Rechner oder läuft das extern, ne ne, das ist, das ist eine, das ist VMWare, das
ist Windows, Windows mit VMWare, so, dann machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie ein paar schöne
Graph, Graph Source, New Dashboard, Add Query, On Prometheus, also, eine Sache hab ich festgestellt,
was man machen kann, also das hab ich, das hab ich in der Präsentation von dem Typ gesehen,
es gibt eine Standardmetrik, die Prometheus exportiert, das ist ab, das ist der Host Status
und der Host Status ist in dem Fall 1, die haben auch nur ein Host drin, nämlich so den
Local Host, wo der, also standardmäßig, wo das Prometheus drauf läuft, und jetzt haben
wir den Graph, stellen wir einen mal auf, sag mal 5 Minuten, 15 Minuten, 15 Minuten und
speichern wir mal, ja, das war's, also ich hab Grafana schon mal, ich hab Grafana benutzt
für Batteriestände von meinem Heim, Automatisierungszeug, aber ich bin jedes Mal, wenn ich den Graf
benutzen muss, begeistert, wie intuitiv und simpel die das gemacht haben, das ist wirklich
schön, ja, so, jetzt haben wir einen Graph, der Graph ist jetzt nicht wirklich sinnvoll,
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen, weil, ich mein, Host Status in einem Graph, der Host Status
kann 0 sein für Down oder 1 für Up, also, ist jetzt als Graph nicht so sinnvoll, deswegen
versuchen wir mal, meine, meine, von meinem Router versuchen wir mal zu importieren, da
hab ich nämlich im Vorfeld schon nachgeguckt, da gibt's was, von meinem Router versuchen
wir mal zu importieren die Interfaces und die Bites pro Sekunde, glaub das ist ein schöneres
Beispiel, was man als Graph machen kann, hattest du nicht damals auch mal Sambajon verwendet,
nicht dass ich wüsste, es kann durchaus sein, dass ich es mal ausprobiert hab, aber, nicht
dass ich wüsste, kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, äh, soll ich mal kurz ausmachen,
weil ich was gucken muss, obbei, ach, wurscht, guck ich, guck ich, guck ich später, das,
das finde ich bei Amazon Musik ganz gut, die haben so eine Lautstärke Anpassung, dass alles
so ein Vergleichlaut ist, hab ich, ja, ist wieder an, was eigentlich aus dem 10G nass
geworden, das steht hier immer noch rum, also die Teile, steht immer noch alles rum, das
könnten wir auch mal überwachen gleich, so, aber ja, das war ein Graph für Host Abtime,
das ist kacke, also was ich haben möchte ist, das muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert,
ich möchte einmal ne Übersicht haben, so ne kleine hier, so ne kleine Tabelle, wo alle
meine Hosts drinnen stehen und einfach nur dahinter steht, ob der ab oder down ist, für
den Fall der Fände, dass er mal wieder abkackt, wie der Raspberry im Keller, ich hätte gern
also so, was mir so vorschwebt ist, ähm, das ist welches Lied, das ist Bad Religion,
das glaubt das letzte Album von ihm, ähm, der erste Song, ich hab grad angemacht, ähm,
so, und ich hätte gern hier so quasi so ne Tabelle mit Hoststatus ab, down, so ein bisschen
wie man das, wie man das im Nagios hat, falls, falls noch irgendjemand, äh, ups, falls noch
irgendwer Nagios kennt, kann es, warum ist das so fies, darf ich wieder Bilder machen,
also ich hätte gerne einmal so ne Tabelle, sowas in der Richtung, äh, äh, sowas in
der Richtung hier hätte ich einmal gerne, was mir einfach anzeigt, host down oder ab,
so hier links, und dann rechts, zum Ausprühen würde ich sagen, machen wir mal die, wir
versuchen mal, den, die Festplattenbelegung vom Raspberry abzufliegen, äh, abzufliegen,
abzuziehen, abzufliegen, und die, und von meinem Router die Bites pro Sekunde, die übers
Interface gehen, mal gucken, also als erstes versuch ich einmal hier host up, host down
irgendwie hinzukriegen, also host up, host down ist schonmal in Grav-Form ziemlich unsinnig,
man konnte nämlich, man kann ja auswählen, dass man das ganze als Tabelle haben will,
wie kriege ich jetzt als Tabelle, wie kriege ich ne Up-Down-Tabelle, ich mein die Werte
hab ich, aber ich will eigentlich nur den letzten Wert anzeigen, also gibt's sowas
wie last, ok hier kann man schonmal Farben vergeben, für wie kritisch was ist, wie könnte
man das jetzt konfigurieren, dass das, ah, nice, das ist doch schon fast das was wir
haben wollen, so als Format wollen wir nur noch anzeigen, den Jobname, also was quasi
der Host ist, so und jetzt wissen wir schonmal, Status, erstmal speichern, so jetzt haben
wir schonmal ne Tabelle, die mir anzeigt ob meine Hosts up oder down sind, aber das sieht
doch ein bisschen kacke aus, ahm, dann machen wir mal diesen Farbmodus ein, ahm, wie geht
das jetzt, mein 1 ist up, 1 ist gut, 0, äh, äh, wie geht denn das, Komma Separated, sowas
hier, 0, 1, ah, gut, interessant, ok jetzt haben wir ne Anzeige ob mein Host up oder
down ist, hoffentlich wenn da 0 drin steht, jetzt mappen wir das noch mal auf, jetzt kann
man nämlich sagen, wenn da 1 drin steht, dann wollen wir Text, ok und wenn da wahrscheinlich
0 drin steht, dann machen wir Error, oder, oder, down schreiben wir da rein, dann schreiben
wir up oder down rein, ok und jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Host um das ganze auszuprobieren,
das ist doch schonmal ganz nice, browse per page auf 1, äh, weiß ich nicht, ich hab ja
gar nicht mehr, 1 Poggers, 2 Pepehands, jetzt kommt das, das wird nicht gut, ah Moment,
kann man hier vielleicht, kann man die HTML rein machen, da könnte ich für up, da mach
ich für up Poggers rein, ah, wo geht das, ich glaub das bezieht sich auf was anderes
hier oder, Moment, da kann man HTML reinschreiben, ok Moment, ne, Moment, geht das, geht das,
geht das, kann man HTML rein machen, allow text, aber ich mein, warum, warum gibt's
den Knopf für HTML bereinigen, wenn, wenn es doch gar nicht geht, ha, gut, äh, äh,
wir lassen das jetzt erstmal so, so und jetzt brauchen wir noch einen zweiten Host, entweder
machen wir jetzt dann den Raspberry, wir machen jetzt den Raspberry, wir machen den Raspberry
rein würde ich sagen, ne, Type ist doch für den Input, nicht das, ich hab keine Ahnung,
ich benutze das so selten, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber ne, das, das, das, das,
also ich vermute mal, dass Type, das hier ist, wie ich das hier irgendwie transformieren
kann, weil wenn ich das hier auf Swing stelle, ach so, ah ja, das kann natürlich sein, das
kann natürlich sein, dass wenn jetzt quasi in dem Value hier schon irgendwas drinstehen
würde, dass er sich darauf bezieht, dass ich HTML bereinigen kann, also angenommen hier
in diesem Wert, der quasi, wie Endes die Menschen schon gesagt haben, als Input rein kommt,
wenn da HTML drinstehen wird, also das bereinigt, ah ok, ne, da kann ich hier kein HTML reinschreiben,
ok, ja, das leuchtet, leuchtet ein, wobei, wobei ich mich nicht wundern würde, wenn
man nicht hier doch irgendwie Bilder rein kriegt, ok, also auf jeden Fall, also Up ist Poggers
und was, was hatten wir gesagt Down ist?
Aber jetzt erst mal nur Techstars stehen da, ok, so jetzt brauchen wir einen zweiten Host,
dann nehmen wir jetzt mal den Raspberry zu, der da, so, ähm, da müssen wir jetzt den,
den Node-Exporter, den aktuellen Node-Exporter installieren, das, die haben für alles irgendwie
extra Namen erfunden, ja, bei allen anderen Monitoring-Lösungen nennt sich hier sowas
Agent, aber Prometheus ist das der Node-Exporter, es ergibt auch irgendwo Sinn, weil wenn ich
das in der Präsentation richtig verstanden hab, ähm, ist es nicht so, dass du da drüber
irgendwelche extra Checks ausführen kannst oder so, sondern einfach nur, dass quasi eingesammelt
wird von Prometheus, was der jeweilige Node-Exporter eben schon auf dem Rechner eingesammelt hat
und bereitstellt, also es ist ok, dass es Node-Exporter heißt, aber es ist wie so oft,
dass jemand der, dass, dass sie für alles irgendwelche neuen Namen brauchen, ja, also
das ist quasi der Agent, den man auf Systeme installiert und man muss ihn nicht unbedingt
auf Systeme installieren, es gibt beispielsweise auch Node-Exporter für Mikrotik-Switches
oder Mikrotik-Router, das probieren wir jetzt nämlich gleich mal aus, weil da hab ich hier
hinten einen stehen, der dann die Sachen quasi, wie Bites pro Sekunde vom Interface vom Router
exportiert nach, nach Prometheus und man kann schön das Dashboard raus machen. Ok,
ähm, jetzt, wir laden jetzt erstmal den Node-Exporter runter für den Raspberry, da müssen wir
gucken, dass wir die richtige Architektur finden, weil das hier ist ein, das hier ist
ein, äh, Arm-Arm4-6 Raspberry Pi Zero V, das heißt wir brauchen hier auch das Paket
für Arm-4-6 oder spricht man überhaupt richtig aus, Arm-4-6, Arm-6, für Arm-4-6, so, entpacken
wir den Kram mal und, ähm, anscheinend muss man das einfach nur starten und das war's,
kann ich. Einfach starten, dann geht man in seine Prometheus-Config, die hat Standard
auf, aber die hab ich hier schon gesehen, dann geht man in seine Prometheus-Config,
ich mach das alles nur anhand dem, was ich, was ich mir eben auf YouTube als Video angeguckt
hab, dann geht man in seine Konfig rein und sagt ihm, man möchte einen neuen Host hinzufügen
und zwar, ähm, wir wollen jetzt hinzufügen meinen Relay Pi, ne, hab ich das Ding genannt,
weil er irgendwie das von meiner, von meiner Tür Gegensprechanlage Relate und das ist
nicht Localhost, das ist, das kann man übrigens auch bei DNS-Namen machen und ich hab gelesen,
man kann es auch komplett automatisch discoveren lassen, aus dem Text-File oder über DNS
oder über irgendwelche anderen Registry-Dinger, also man muss da nicht jeden Host von Hand
eintragen, aber zum Ausprobieren ist das jetzt erstmal am besten. So, so und jetzt,
wenn ich das jetzt neu starte, müsste ich, die richtige Musik, ja, ähm, wenn ich das
jetzt starte, wenn ich jetzt Prometheus starte, müsste ich in meinem Frontend einen zweiten
Rechner sehen, nämlich meinen Raspberry. So weit von der Theorie her zumindest. Ah,
da ist er. Das ist ja cool. So und jetzt können wir nämlich gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das
Ding mitkriegt, wenn der Down geht. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Also, wir gucken auch mal
wie schnell. Ich mach jetzt erstmal die Schriftgröße hier ein bisschen größer, 20 oder so. So,
aktuell ist mein Prometheus Server ab und mein Raspberry ist auch ab. Und jetzt machen
wir den Raspberry mal so fake-mäßig aus und dann gucken wir mal wie schnell er das
Ganze mitkriegt. Nice. Das ging schnell. Und das ging echt ziemlich simpel, jetzt muss
ich's sagen. Das ist super, jetzt stellen wir bloß nochmal die Farbe um, dass rot ist.
Das ist echt einfach. Das ist wirklich einfach. Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. So und jetzt
mach ich ihn mal wieder an. Also, quasi Raspberry abgekackt, Raspberry startet neu, Raspberry
ist neu gestartet. Müsste eigentlich gleich wieder auf Poggers gehen. Poggers!
Echt denn schlecht? Also, ich bin wirklich überrascht, wie simpel das ist, ey. Also,
beim Nagios werden wir jetzt noch ein Nagios-Config erstellen, bei Zapix werden wir jetzt ein
Templates erstellen, dass es installiert. Im Prinzip ein RPM-Repo hinzu, äh, nicht,
Apt-Repo hinzugefügt, äh, Debia, also ein Uponto-Repo hinzugefügt, ein Binary runtergeladen,
2 Binaries runtergeladen, gestartet, Paket installiert, ein bisschen im Webinterface rumgeklickt
und wir haben schon eine Tabelle, ob host up oder down ist. Das ist echt gut. Ja, Grafana
installiert, genau. Das ist wirklich cool. So, und jetzt probieren wir mal, ob ich noch
von meinem Router, wie das die Cisco Fanboys sagen, ähm, ein paar Statistiken kriege.
Ne, Schwachsinn, bevor wir das machen, jetzt können wir mal das Eigentliche machen, ich
möchte ja wissen, wie viel Platz ich noch frei habe auf meinem Raspberry. Das ist ja
der eigentliche Knackpunkt, warum ich das überhaupt machen will, weil das Ding abgekackt
ist, weil SD-Karte voll. Ok, also, wir haben, also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ich hab
einen Note-Exporter auf meinem Raspberry laufen. Der exportiert jetzt auch irgendwie, wie die
Festplattenbelegung ist. Das müssen wir mal nachgucken. Und zwar, schauen wir mal hier
nach, was das Ding exportiert. War das hier? Ne. War das hier? Ne. Doch hier. Hier kann
man nachgucken. Also sprich, alles dieser Mist exportiert automatisch, ohne dass ich
was konfiguriert habe, einfach nur durch Starten des Note-Exporters. Alle diese Infos
von dem System werden quasi exportiert und kann ich hier in Grafana für meinen Graph
verwenden. Und da ist doch jetzt bestimmt auch irgendwie sowas drin, wie File-System-Belegung
oder sowas. Space. Ach hier. Note File-System Available Bytes. Ok, das heißt, wir machen
mal einen neuen Graph. Und da kommt jetzt die Festplattenbelegung von meinem Raspberry
rein. Ich bin, bis jetzt bin ich wirklich begeistert, wie einfach das ist. Das ist wirklich
sehr nice. Viel einfacher als Tubbix rumgewürge da. Also ich mein, ok, ich will das mal Tubbix
nicht so schlecht machen, wie gesagt, wir haben das auf der Arbeit auch und der tut
auch seinen Job und für ne große Umgebung, also für ne komplexe Infrastruktur mit über
mehrere Rechenzentren und alles. Also, es hat Tubbix auf jeden Fall seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Aber so ne kleine Lite-Wise-Lösung für daheim, finde ich, ist hier mit Prometheus und Grafana
viel angenehmer. Also wirklich viel angenehmer als Tubbix. Wenn man Tubbix konfigurieren
muss, der kriegt ganz viel, oder? Kuchencraft, please. Haben die sowas überhaupt? Wir haben
nur so nen Tacho. Einen Tacho hätten wir zu bieten. Geht das auch? Shadow Ghost? Geht
so nen Tacho? Geht das auch? Aber wir können mal gucken. Die haben doch, das schöne an
Grafana ist, die haben online, haben die so nen Marketplace. Nein, schwachsinn. Share
irgendwie heißt das. Also die haben keinen Marketplace, die haben so nen Dashboard, so
ein Dashboard-Share-Plattform. Da gucken wir mal, ob da ein Tortendiagramm ist. Ach
hier. Ne, das ist nicht die. Hier, Grafana.com-Dashboards. Genau. Da können alle Leute quasi ihre Dashboards
sharen. So und auf Englisch heißt Tortendiagramm Piedchart, oder? Sowas will ich, genau. Warum
gibts hier keinen Piedchart? Der stand doch schon bei Graf, wat? Wie krieg ich nen Piedchart?
Grafana Piedchart. Ach hier. Plugins. Grafana Piedchart-Panel. Ach das ist ein Plugin,
ein Dashboard, okay. Und hier kann man auch nicht suchen, oder? Kann man hier suchen?
Das ist doof. Das ist doof, dass man hier nicht suchen kann. Okay, suchen. Auch wahrscheinlich
weil es nicht so viel ist. Hi. Piedchart. Okay, dann fügen wir mal einen Piedchart zu
uns. Da freuen sich jetzt die ganzen BWL-Leute. Install Plugin. Grafana CLI-Plugin install Grafana
Piedchart-Panel. Okay. Äh. Äh Moment, hier müssen wir hin. Restart Grafana. So und jetzt
haben wir nen Piedchart. Ist das so? Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob wir jetzt nen Piedchart
zur Auswahl haben. Nö. Nö. Ah, klick Plugin Items Mainmenu. Okay, vielleicht muss ich
das erst noch aktivieren. Plugins. Hi. Piedchart. Ist doch. Ach, kann man die Sachen auch direkt
hier rüber installieren? Oh, das wäre natürlich... Oh, das ist ja nice. Man kann den Kram hier
drüber installieren. Oder? Nee, doch nicht. Nur das war schön selig. Piedchart. Okay,
jetzt ist es. Okay, wie auch immer das jetzt genau funktioniert. Piedchart. Ah, ansichens
ist es da. New Dashboard Copy. Okay, wir geben dem Dashboard erstmal nen ordentlichen Namen.
Äh, Stats. Was auch immer. Head Panel. Ah. Ah, da ist es doch. Ich hab's doch nicht
gesehen. Ist es doch. Nice. So. Very. Okay, also. Ähm, wie ist das? Node. File. System.
Free Bites. Äh, wisst ihr was? Bevor ich da so nen schönes Piedchart rausmache, wir machen
erstmal kurz nen Graph. Da erkennt man das glaub ich besser. Okay. Also. Free. So, das
sieht schonmal mega hässlich aus. Ich erkenne jetzt, dass ich aktuell hier, ähm, 22 Millionen.
Okay, wir müssen, wir müssen das noch umrechnen. Wir müssen das noch umrechnen glaub ich. Ähm,
Moment. Okay, erstmal Legenden Format. Also wir wollen erstmal da unten nicht den ganzen
Schmodder angezeigt haben, sondern wir wollen einmal die Weiß angezeigt haben und dann
wollen wir Mountpoint angezeigt haben. Mountpoint. Okay, genau. Das, das sieht schon schöner
aus. Dann machst du mal so rum. On. So, slashboot, und die Weiß bla bla bla, slash bla bla bla.
Okay, das, das, das ist doch schonmal, das ist doch schonmal ganz schön. So. Point. Oh,
ist auch nice. So, den ganzen Mist brauche ich jetzt nicht. So, und wenn ich das richtig
in Erinnerung habe, man kann die Sachen rauswerfen. Also ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ähm,
die Weiß, not, oder auch nicht. Wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Die Weiß, slash, äh, FS
Time. Gleich. Und gleich. Äh, hm. Wie, wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Eieiei. Äh. Also
ich hätte wetten können, das funktioniert so. Aber wir speichern das jetzt nochmal.
Gehen wir mal hier auf explore und probieren das mal darüber aus. Da kann man nämlich
ein bisschen besser rum basteln. Node, FileSys, FileSystem, FreeBytes. So, und jetzt will
ich da haben, die, genau, die Weiß, gleich, TempFS, DrillNotTempFS. Geht doch. Was hat
man jetzt für Probleme damit gehabt, oder? So, aber jetzt kann mein Raspberry auch nochmal
voll laufen, klar, weil ich sehe es zumindest. Oh, funktioniert doch. Genau, weil jetzt haben
wir hier bloß noch drinnen. Ähm, übrigens, was jemand gesagt hat, ist voll, vollkommen
richtig. Ähm, es ist umgedreht. Es ist DeviceOnMountPoint. Ok, slashboot ist klar, dass es da unten rumhängt.
Aber wie kriegen wir das jetzt mit den Einheiten richtig hin? Hallo, Deezer, ja, ich lege,
ich lege noch. Wie kriegen wir das mit den Einheiten richtig hin? Man konnte irgendwo
hier einstellen, Unit. Unit, genau. Unit ist Bytes. Was eher mit MetricBytes. Ja, oh,
ist das cool. Sehr nice. Stimmt das denn überhaupt? Also, der sagt jetzt, dass auf
Boot aktuell 22 MB frei sind und auf Root sind 27 GB frei. Guck mal, ob das stimmt.
Naja, je nachdem, wie der rechnet, kann das schon hinkommen. Naja, doch, je nachdem, wie
der rechnet, kann das hinkommen. Ob der 1000 oder 1024 macht. Und auf Boot sind 22. Auf
Boot sind 22, ja, das passt. Ja, das sind, das sind, das sind Umrechnungsgeschichten.
Aber das ist schön. Das ist wirklich schön. So, und jetzt muss ich jemanden irgendwie
noch beibringen. Also ich meine, jetzt sehe ich, wie viel Platz hier, wie viel Platz
noch frei ist. Ja, das war es doch eigentlich, oder? Also jetzt sehe ich, wie viel Platz
noch frei ist. Und wenn das hier halt, sag mal mal, irgendwie dann demnächst irgendwie
bei einem Gigabyte ist oder so, dann weiß ich, okay, das Ding läuft gleich voll. Gab's
da nicht noch AvailableBytes statt FreeBytes? Ja, gab's, aber ich würde jetzt fast vermuten,
dass, also für mich klingt AvailableBytes und FreeBytes dann exakt dem gleichen. Ist
da ein Unterschied? Ah, ah, kann es sein, dass das anders rechnet? Nee, oder? Hä? Was
bitteschön ist der Unterschied zwischen AvailableBytes und FreeBytes? Das ist doch genau das gleiche.
So was sprechen. Okay, das eine ist wahrscheinlich 1024, das andere ist 1000. 5% oder so werden
zur Sicherheit reserviert. Nö, nix reserviert. Also, standardmäßig nicht. Nö, nö. Also
wenn ich jetzt hier einfach mal die Idee machen würde, würde ich, könnte ich ohne Probleme
die Platte vollschreiben. FreeBytes. FreeBytes. InBytes. Okay. AvailableBytes. InBytes. Was
auch immer. Scheiß drauf, die Ausgabe ist besser, weil die Ausgabe identisch ist mit
DF. Ja gut, Moment, jetzt läuft das, nee. Also, ohne Quotas oder so, wüsste ich nicht,
warum, warum du irgendwie einen Limit haben solltest, dass einer was nicht vollschreiben
kann. Ja, mit I-Notes reserviert, das kann sein, aber du kannst normalerweise ohne Probleme
eine Festplatte vollschreiben mit Logs. Ah, okay, verstehe. Wo habe ich jetzt die Metrics?
Ich hab's doch eben zugemacht gerade. Wir gucken, wir gucken jetzt noch mal kurz an,
was da jetzt genau dran steht. AvailableBytes. Achso, SpaceEval to Non-Root. Achso. Aha,
tatsächlich. Siehst du mal, manchmal kann man auch auf den Chat hören. Interessant.
Aber normalerweise kannst du als User auch das File-Stamp vollschreiben. Es kann sein,
dass ein paar I-Notes reserviert sind, aber ansonsten. Also. Ich würde wundern, wenn
das nicht geht, weil das kommt bei uns öfters mal vor, dass irgendwelche Logs das Ding vollmachen,
weil, weil halt, ja. Gut, die liegen aber auch nicht auf Root. Also, das wäre mir jetzt
neu, dass man eine Festplatte als User nicht vollschreiben kann. Man könnte das mal ausprobieren.
Nee, ich will es jetzt aber nicht ausprobieren. Ich hatte mal das Problem bei mir, dass ich
nichts verschreiben konnte, obwohl noch ein paar Gigabyte frei war. Nee, das kann vorkommen.
Es kann sein, dass deine I-Notes aufgebraucht sind. Das kommt relativ oft vor, wenn du,
wenn du Kleinscheiß hast. Also ganz, ganz kleine Files. Ein paar Bites oder, ja. Und
davon hast du ganz viele. Aber es ist interessant, das wusste ich nicht. Das wusste ich gar nicht,
dass man als normaler User Root nicht vollschreiben kann. Schau mal, man lernt nicht aus. Ich dachte
eigentlich so die Basics und das würde ich mal zu Basics zählen. Könnte mir keiner mehr
irgendwas Neues erzählen, aber das ist interessant, das wusste ich schon nicht. Aber wie gesagt,
es ist mir auch noch nie aufgefallen, dass das wohl nicht möglich ist. Also das kommt bei uns
laufend vor, dass irgendwelche Dinger irgendwas vollschreiben. Aber das ist tatsächlich alles
nicht schlecht Root. Aber wir hatten auch schon Dinger, wo Root voll war. Besonders gerne mal
kommt das vor, wenn irgendwelches Java-Zeug abkackt und dann erst mal 25G Heap-Dump schreibt und ist
dann auch mal ganz schnell vorbei. Das machen uns die Java-Programmierer gern. Die haben das
eingeschaltet, dass dann Heap gedumpt wird und dann dampft das erst mal 96G Heap oder sowas.
Zumindest, ich bin also mit dieser, hier mit der Stat-Pro-Metals-Geschichte finde ich das
wirklich sehr, sehr nice, weil im Endeffekt habe ich die wichtigen Sachen hier jetzt schon drinne.
Speichern wir das Ganze nochmal, save, jawoll. Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt den Übersicht,
also ich mache hier noch alle anderen Raspberries rein. Stromverbrauch, wenn es geht. Stromverbrauch
funktioniert. Das müsste ich aus meinem Heim-Automatisierung-System exportieren,
irgendwie in den Influx-DB oder sowas. Und dann Pile-Chart, ja Pile-Chart machen wir jetzt,
sofort, Pile-Chart machen wir gleich. Und dann könnte ich das ins Grafana machen,
wobei ich den Stromverbrauch in meinem Heim-Automatisierung-System drinstehen habe und
nachschauen kann, also das brauche ich im Grafana nicht. Also das hier setze ich wirklich rein hin
für System-Monitoring, dass ich weiß, was meine Infrastruktur nennt, was man daheim macht. So,
Pile-Chart wollten wir machen. Also irgendwie scheint der Shadow-Ghost total geil auf Pile-Charts zu
sein. Bist du dir sicher, dass du nicht irgendwie den Beruf verfehlen hast oder so? Weil eigentlich
Leute, die auf Pile-Charts stehen, sind meistens nicht Leute, die auf Technik stehen. Ja gut,
das funktioniert jetzt hier natürlich jetzt nicht. Das funktioniert jetzt hier natürlich nicht,
weil das sind Pile-Charts, das sind 100% und davon sind die unterschiedlichen BWLer in Diskales.
Das müssen wir jetzt anders machen. Dem müssten wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, dass das ein Pile-Chart,
das müssten wir für einen Wert machen und dann irgendwie gucken von 100. Also quasi wir
können Anzeigen lassen im Pile-Chart, free used könnte man machen. Da weiß ich aber ehrlich
gesagt nicht, wie das funktioniert. Also sprich, wir bräuchten zwei Werte, wir bräuchten free
und used und dann müssten wir schauen, dass wir das halt irgendwie in das Pile-Chart als die Werte
reinkriegen. Free percentage gibt es glaube ich nicht exportiert. Einfach eine andere Variableorte,
da hören wir uns aber mal meine Grafana-Erkenntnisse auf. Okay, probieren wir aus. Add Query. Okay,
jetzt haben wir hier Available Bites, dann machen wir Node File System Size, hieß das glaube ich.
Oder Shadow Ghost, mit dem Pile-Chart gibst du dich noch nicht zufrieden, oder? Gehe ich da richtig
in der Annahme? Das ist noch nicht Pile-Chart mäßig genug. Also ich würde mich damit auch
nicht zufrieden geben. Das sieht noch nicht gut aus. Ja Moment, aber das ist doch jetzt
schon, das ist doch schon die Ausgabe oder? Das passt doch jetzt schon. Das da, das da ist,
das da ist quasi used, nee das ist Gesamtsize, das ist Gesamtsize. Oh jetzt müssen wir wieder
Quickmaps machen. Used 4, used, okay, okay, der ist falsch rum. Erstmal wieder Musik anmachen.
Oh ich glaube ich habe jetzt mit, ich glaube ich habe den Shadow Ghost geflamed, da ist jetzt nicht
mal da. Das war nicht so gemeint. Es kann auch durchaus Informatiker und Technikbegeisterte geben,
die Pile-Charts mögen. Heute ist ja auch wieder so ein Tag, wo jeder sein darf, was er will und
man kann ohne Probleme als Technikbegeisterte auch Pile-Charts mögen. Hyper-Bullying, Hyper-Cyber-Bullying,
was dann? So wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit? Also das ist ja offensichtlich falsch, was ich
mir da anzeigen lasse. Also ich gucke mir Bites Available an und Size in Bites. Ich brauche
jetzt allerdings sowas wie Used. So und Used kriege ich doch eigentlich nur hin, wenn ich
quasi das da minus das da rechne, oder? Jaaa. Gibt doch einen Export dafür. Also Dr. House,
ich habe nicht so großartig Ahnung davon von Grafana. Also ich weiß nicht was ein Export ist.
Meinst du Export ist das da? Okay was meinst du soll ich nehmen? Also ich sehe hier bloß Size
insgesamt. Ich sehe jetzt da bloß die Dinger. Es gibt Available Bites und es gibt Size Bites, mehr gibt es nicht.
Vielleicht muss man das noch irgendwie einschalten, dass er das exportiert.
Die Free Bites haben wir schon ausprobiert. Free Bites ist einfach nur eine andere
Umrechnungsvariante. Aber das ist doch jetzt genau das was wir brauchen, ne? Und das hier, okay das
Pie Chart pie chartet noch ein bisschen mehr für Boot, aber Boot brauchen wir nicht. Aber von der
Idee her ist das doch hier eigentlich schon mal ganz nice. Also sprich, das hier ist quasi
insgesamt Size und davon ist noch so und so viel free. Bist du mit so einem Pie Chart zufrieden?
Wobei ich ehrlich sage, ich finde das als Pie Chart gar nicht so schön. Denn ein Nachteil hat das
Ganze nämlich mit dem Pie Chart. Man sieht keine Trends. Deswegen werde ich das Ganze wieder
umstellen auf einen normalen Craft, weil dann sieht man nämlich den Trend. Dann stellen wir das nämlich
ein. Wenn man das dann beispielsweise auf zwei Wochen einstellt, dann sehe ich nämlich den Trend
und den Trend sehe ich im Pie Chart nicht richtig. Also in dem Fall finde ich das schon sinnvoller
mit einem normalen Craft zu machen. So nachdem das Bites free sind, also sprich sollte der Craft mal
irgendwann hier unten angekommen sein. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Leute, das probieren wir jetzt
mal aus, ob das funktioniert. Also von der Idee her ist das so, ich erstelle jetzt mal eine 5G,
eine 5G, was Query ist falsch? Warum? Für jeden, für jeden Darken Pie Chart. Ja, das könnte man
natürlich auch machen. Warum ist das Query falsch? Funktioniert doch. Ich erstelle mal.
Ah, du hast recht, ich hab das falsche gelöst. Available war das richtige. Ah ja, manche Sachen
fallen einfach nicht auf. Okay, dann speichern wir den Kram jetzt mal und jetzt erstellen wir
mal eine, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Wir erstellen jetzt mal eine, also 25 sind frei. Das
sagt der DF im Prinzip auch, ein bisschen anders gerundet, aber okay. So, ich erstelle jetzt mal
eine 5Gigabyte Datei, mal ein bisschen meine SSD belasten. Ich erstelle jetzt mal eine 5Gigabyte
Datei und da gucken wir mal, ob das hier runtergeht. Gucken wir mal, mal schauen. Irgendwie war es
für sich. Machen wir mal ein M. Wir machen, wir fangen mal langsam an, ja. Wir erstellen mal 100,
wir erstellen mal eine 1Gigabyte Datei. Kannst du auch Benachrichtigungen erstellen? Ja, das geht
auch irgendwie, da hab ich aber noch nicht nachgeguckt, wie das funktioniert. Okay,
die Idee muss man immer aufpassen, was man da so macht, sonst macht man Mist. Def Zero nach Bin.
Achso. Wir erstellen jetzt eine 1Gigabyte Datei. Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, seht ihr das,
der Graph geht runter. Habt ihr schon, ich finde der Graph ist schon ein bisschen, oder? Oder? Der
geht runter, oder Leute? Ja, guck mal, der geht runter. Ich meine, die SD-Karte ist lahm. Die SD-Karte
ist langsam. Wir können mal ranzoomen. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass es dieser Graph hier komplett
versaut, weil hier ist nämlich was mit 22 MB drinne. Wie komm ich denn dahin? Ja, aber guckt,
Leute, es geht runter. Es geht auf jeden Fall runter. Wir werfen Boot da jetzt noch mal raus.
Da sieht man es, glaube ich, schöner. Matt, das stimmt. Allerdings, es gibt die neuen,
die DS haben mittlerweile selbst ein Procress Bar. Die neuen DS haben das mittlerweile. Ich
kann mir aber auch immer nicht merken, wie man das, Status gleich Procress, genau. Die
neuen DS können das. Es ist noch nicht so lange drinne. Es gibt erst seit 20 Jahren oder so. Nee,
Schwachsinn. Bei solchen Tools sind 20 Jahre nicht viel. Nee, ich glaube, das gibt es wirklich
erst ein, zwei Jahre oder so. Oder, dass es zumindest bei den größeren Distros angekommen
ist. Das ist noch relativ neu. Guck mal hier, es ist wieder runter, es ist wieder hoch.
Also, das funktioniert. Ich schreibe jetzt mal meine SD-Karte gerade kaputt. Wo kehr's?
So, eine Frage halte ich jetzt doch noch. Wie kriege ich denn das hier raus? Ach so, nee,
ich sag einfach, ich sag einfach, Mountpoint ist, ich sag einfach mal Mountpoint ist, oder was,
FS-Type? Nee, wie ging das? Ich muss doch mal den Explorer aufmachen. Load. Free. Free. Free
Bites. Lampen haben wir dazu. Ich will Mountpoint slash Mountpoint will ich haben. Mountpoint,
das will ich haben. Das will ich haben. Guckt, jetzt sieht man das auch richtig gut.
Jetzt können wir mal zugucken. Refresht das noch? Oder spackt das rum? Ja, das
refresht noch. Jetzt zoomen wir hier mal rein oder wir zoomen jetzt hier mal rein, aber dann
refresht das dann automatisch. Refresht das jetzt? Nee, natürlich refresht das jetzt nicht. Wir
machen einfach mal die letzten fünf Minuten und refresht. Und den Graf ein bisschen kursern. Jetzt
gucken wir mal zu, wie das hier läuft. Refresht der noch? Ja, er refresht noch. Okay, ich mach
das CD mal wieder an. Jetzt gucken wir mal zu, wie sich das bewegt. Ich hätte die Datei vorher
löschen sollen, oder? Moment, ich hätte die Datei vorher löschen sollen. Funktioniert
das nicht. Die alte Datei erstmal gelöscht, jetzt macht er die neue. Ja, okay, es funktioniert.
Hier hat er wahrscheinlich die alte Datei erstmal gelöscht, bevor er die neue geschrieben hat.
Es funktioniert, es sollte jetzt noch weiter runter gehen. Wahrscheinlich ist es aber, ja,
es funktioniert, sehr nice. Und was der auch noch in der Präsentation gezeigt hat, ist,
das Ding kann auch irgendwelche Trends, also sprich, man kann ihm sogar sagen, also Prometheus kann
dann quasi gucken, sollte dieser Trend so weitergehen, in wieviel Stunden wäre dann meine Platte voll?
Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie das funktioniert. Kannst du auch mal bei der Glocke links gucken,
was man da einstellt, klar? Okay, aber das funktioniert gut. Das funktioniert gut. So,
und jetzt löschen wir die Datei nochmal. Meine Katze findet das übrigens super entspannt auf dem
Schrank, die guckt mir jetzt zu, wie ich das hier mache. So, und jetzt sollte das, wenn Cache und
so und alles wieder gesynced ist, sollte das eigentlich wieder hoch gehen. Irgendwann dann
zack, zack, zack. Sehr schön. So, was soll ich gucken bei der Glocke links? Nee, Glocke links,
die Glocke links, ach hier, Alerting. Ja, da kann man einstellen, dass man Nachrichten kriegt.
Da kann man, kann man dann über Slack und sowas sich was verschicken lassen,
ja. Oder über Dingding. Von Dingding habe ich noch nie was gehört. Dingding. Tolle Notifications,
sowas. Dingding. Also man kann anscheinend, Webhooks, Webhooks ist schon mal ganz toll,
dass man über Webhooks verschicken kann, weil da kann ich Heimautomatisierungs-Sachen
triggern lassen. Kein Meta-Maus. Nee, aber Webhooks. Dadurch, dass Webhooks funktionieren,
funktioniert quasi so ziemlich alles andere auch. Hallo, Zellmoor als Pager-Duty. Prometheus,
Alert-Manager kann man anstreuen, E-Mail natürlich, Push-Over kann man sich,
da kann man sich über Push-Over kann man sich dann zum Beispiel aufs iPhone eine
Nachricht schicken lassen, wenn der Server down ist oder so. Und was kann man bei Rules einstellen?
Ach nee, das macht man, Moment, das macht man im Graph, ne? Das macht man im Graph.
Das macht man im Graph hier, da kann man einstellen. Also da kann ich zum Beispiel sagen,
hier unten bei Alert, also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, also wenn ist über, ist below,
in welche Einheit schreibe ich das da jetzt rein? Jaja, also Tribolone, alle Alerts mache ich da
auf jeden Fall noch rein. Das war jetzt bloß zum Test erstmal nicht klar. Okay, ist below,
dann machen wir es mal anders, ist above, dass der Alert auf jeden Fall jetzt angeht, ist above,
keine Ahnung, 10. Ach guck mal, der zeigt es einem an. Okay, das ist cool. Das ist sehr praktisch,
okay, ist below, 10. Ah, da kann man nicht durcheinander kommen mit Einheiten. Der zeigt
dann schon gleich an, wo das ungefähr ist. Oh, das ist ja geil. Also ich muss euch sagen,
ich bin jedes Mal begeistert, wenn ich Grafana verwende, wie durchdacht das Web-Interface ist.
Da kann sich Zappix echt ein riesen Dings von abschneiden. Das ist auch super intuitiv, ja.
Ich sage, okay, ich weiß, ich will das, wenn es hier drunter ist, ja, zack. Okay, ist below,
da machen wir, wir gucken mal gleich nach. Also ist, ist, ist, ist below, machen wir mal hier. So,
und dann erstellen wir auf dem Raspberry noch mal eine Datei und gucken, ob der Alert anschlägt.
Also ist below, 25630239521, das natürlich, was sonst. Okay, ach so, und dann auch noch für lange.
Ah, das heißt nur, wenn es für länger als fünf Minuten. Okay, das lassen wir mal so eingestellt.
No data and error handling. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ah, das ist, wenn Grafana selbst ein Problem hat
oder Prometheus selbst ein Problem hat. Send to message. Ich will eigentlich gar nichts senden.
Ich will einfach nur angucken, ob es anzeigt. Benutzt du Grafana Prometheus mit Docker? Der
hat Prometheus Statistik, nein, ich habe da mein Raspberry gerade drin. Also letztendlich läuft
das Prometheus und das Grafana gerade auf dem Container, ja, aber das ist mein Raspberry,
der gerade abgefragt wird. Okay, kann man das jetzt speichern schon mal? Okay, das hier ist die
Alert Grenze. Ach, die zeigt er auch an. Okay, das ist, das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Kann
ich jetzt nicht sagen, Admin oder so. Wie kann man das löschen? Okay, was auch immer. Ich gehe mal
davon aus, ich kriege es angezeigt. Ach, kommt mal, jetzt zeigt er mir auch an, alles ist grün. Okay,
jetzt zeigt er mir an, alles in Ordnung, alles grün. Wunderbar. Okay, jetzt erstellen wir noch
mal eine Datei auf dem Raspberry und gucken mal zu, wie das Ganze wieder runtergeht.
Klar, kannst du Docker, natürlich kannst du Docker auf dem Raspberry installieren. Keine Frage.
Da hast du recht, klar. Habe ich aber nicht drauf, weil ich habe da nichts Großartiges,
was ich vercontinuerisieren möchte oder als Container benutzen will. Da laufen zwei, drei
Skrips drauf, die Sachen von der Heizung abfragen, das war's. So, jetzt ist er unterhalb von dem
Alerting Level, aber wahrscheinlich muss er das für fünf Minuten sein, dass es anschlägt. Vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal, das haben wir eingestellt. Das ist was Grafana eigenes, I am Groot. Den
Alertmanager von Prometheus habe ich nicht installiert, das scheint irgendwas Grafana
eigenes zu sein. Okay, dann stellen wir das in den Settings gerade nochmal um. Wir stellen in den
Aber selbst dann würde es nicht anschlagen, weil ich Query ja nur fünf Minuten und dann nehme
ich den Durchschnitt, also sprich, wenn der Durchschnitt innerhalb von fünf Minuten,
wobei das ist gar nicht so blöd. Das ist gar nicht so blöd, also sprich, der fängt dann auch
schon an zu meckern, wenn es hier runtergeht. Also nicht direkt, wenn es runtergeht, sondern so ab hier,
wenn halt der Durchschnitt da drunter liegt. Ein Durchschnitt? Also für mich sieht sich das
so, für mich liest sich das so, der Query nimmt sich fünf Minuten von meiner Disk Usage, guck mal,
jetzt ist nämlich auch auf Orange gegangen. Der Query fünf Minuten von fünf Minuten bis jetzt,
Disk Usage und dann nimmt er den Durchschnitt davon. Achso, ja, wieder noch am basteln. Guck mal,
jetzt hat er es erkannt, jetzt hat er festgestellt. Aha, guck mal da, das ist Warning quasi. So und
wenn dieser Zustand jetzt fünf Minuten bestehen bleibt, dann schickt er eine Nachricht, also keine
Nachricht, weil ich habe keine Notificationsachen hinterlegt. Sieht man irgendwo hier im Web
Interface auch Alerts? Ach hier. Ok, wenn der jetzt über fünf Minuten drinsteht, dann würde er
benachrichtigen wahrscheinlich. Das ist cool, also das ist, also vom Einstiegsgrad her und
von der Lernkurve her ist Zappix da ein Witz, also nein, das ist ein Witz gegen Zappix. Zappix
musste erst mal drei Webcasts gucken und das Zappix Handbuch unter das Kopfkissen legen,
dass du ein paar Templates erstellen kannst. Das hier ist dagegen wirklich super, ja. Ok,
also was, Pro Tip, you can include images in your Alert Notifications, da können wir unsere
Poggers rein machen endlich. Also E-Mail kann er, Pushover kann er, Microsoft Teams, ok,
Opsgenie, Discord, ich könnte mal einen Discord Server was schicken lassen, was eigentlich
ganz interessant ist oder eben auch einen Webhook aufrufen. Mal ausprobieren, wenn da Schnellgelogs
sind. Auf, was weiß ich. Was ist denn das Ding noch für eine IP? Wir gucken mal, ob
der jetzt einen Webhook aufruft. Wir machen einfach mal ein Port auf. Ok, funktioniert.
So, wir machen jetzt mal ein Port auf und tragen bei Alert ein Url, obei, mal gucken,
ob es probiert aufzurufen. Send Test. Achso, blubb. Funktioniert nicht. Ist ja auch kein
HTTP Server dahinter. Kein Web Server dahinter. Dann machen wir hier nochmal die. Das funktioniert
nicht. Kommt nix an, können wir nicht ausprobieren, ob der auch alerten würde. Ja, da muss wahrscheinlich
ein ordentlicher Web Server dahinter laufen. Mal mal Sticks angeben. Aktuell habe ich schon
ein Port auf, das, ne, ne, ne. Aha! Ok, Alert. Seit vier Minuten, ok, in einer Minute müsst
er uns benachrichtigen. Schauen wir mal, ob er das macht. Ich bin da wirklich begeistert
davon, das ist so mal einfach. Eine Sache wollten wir noch machen, ich wollte meinen
Router noch Bites pro Sekunde auslesen. Das gucken wir gleich mal, sollte der Alert hier
anschlagen. Da habe ich nämlich was gefunden, wie man MikroTik Statistik abfragen kann.
Ah, die vier Minuten müssen doch jetzt gleich schon mal rum sein. Was auch cool ist, man
kann dann jetzt irgendwie, wie gesagt, man kann so, man kann Prometheus auch irgendwie
so voraus berechnen lassen quasi, wenn es in dieser Geschwindigkeit weitergehen würde,
wann läuft denn die Platte voll. Was ganz cool ist, da kann man dann reinschreiben in
die Benachrichtigung, so nach dem Motto, Achtung, es ist jetzt unter 50%, wenn das in der Geschwindigkeit
weitergeht, ist die Festplatte übermorgen voll oder so. Was echt cool ist. Alerting,
aber er hat nicht alertet. Warum hat er nicht alertet? Ah, er hat nicht alertet, weil ich
den Channel nicht zugewiesen habe, ne. Ich muss bestimmt den Channel auswählen, hier
wo Vira das verschicken soll. Mache ich das denn? Achso, ja stimmt, da war es doch gerade.
Aha. Ja, aber er verschickt es wahrscheinlich noch mal, weil es schon verschickt wurde.
Aber jetzt probieren wir das mal mit dem Mikrotik-Router aus. Jetzt brauchen wir wahrscheinlich
noch ein kurzes Bild, damit ich wieder fange. Und zwar, ich habe auf GitHub, ich habe was
mit Mikrotik Prometheus, ich habe einen Exporter gefunden, nämlich den hier. Und das habe ich
auf meinem Router vorher schon gemacht, also ich habe einen User eingerichtet, mit einem
super komplizierten Passwort, wo garantiert nie jemand draufkommt. Also, ABCDEFG. Und
jetzt probieren wir mal, ob wir Statistiken von meinem Router ins Prometheus beziehungsweise
ins Grafana exportiert kriegen. Wir brauchen das Ganze wieder für AMD 64. Geht eigentlich
der Alert jetzt wieder? Pending. Achso, ja, okay, wir lassen den mal penden und gucken
ob er uns benachrichtigt, der hat dann irgendwann. Okay, laden wir den Krampel mal runter. So,
kann ich jetzt einfach starten? Ne, das kann man einfach ausführen. So, also wie muss
man das ausführen für den Router? Mikrotik Exporter Single Device User Prometheus. Okay,
also benennen wir das Ding erstmal um, in so und dann führen wir das mal aus. Adresse
von meinem Routerpromer, das ist 12168250, User ist Prometheus, Passwort ist 123456,
ne, ab, ich glaube 123456. Egal, eins von beiden ist es, hab ich vorhin angelegt. Okay,
dann starten wir das jetzt mal und dann sollte er sich auf meinen Router connecten und Metriken
einsammeln. Edge Lord, ja, ich bin offen für Verbesserungsvorschläge oder sagen wir mal
so, in BWL Sprache wird das jetzt natürlich heißen, du hast Optimierungspotenzial erkannt.
So, Export. So, Port 9 4 3 6, weil BWL Passwort liegt, oh Scheiße. Puh. So, und jetzt gehen
wir in unseren Prometheus Ordner und editieren das Jaml, feilen und schreiben den Exporter
für den Router mit rein. Mikrotik, Port, übrigens hier, beste Clipboard Manager, Clipboard
Manager, den man mit Tastatur bedienen kann, beste. Und jetzt mal für die, für die VI
Kenner unter uns und vielleicht lernt ja auch der ein oder andere noch was, wie ist es denn
am einfachsten im VI, das sieht aus wie Rophie, das ist Rophie, wie ist es denn am einfachsten
im VI quasi, das hier zu löschen hinten, auf einmal, das ist, das ist würde ich sagen
so, VI Einsteiger bis fortgeschrittenen Level, das ist noch relativ simple, da brauchst nur
drei Buchstaben für. Zwar man kann VI sagen, dass er alles löschen soll zwischen den beiden
Single Quads, dazu sagt man einfach CI Single Quads, dann macht er alles dazwischen weg.
Also kann man sich so merken, CI ist immer wie Change und I merke ich mir immer viel
für Inner, Change, Inner, Single Quads, dann macht er alles auf einmal weg. So, Local Host
und dann macht er komische Einrückungsdinger, die er nicht tun soll. Ich hab Nano, Nano
ist nicht Hacker genug. Vim ist Big Brain. Ok, jetzt haben wir hier ein Local Host-Dings
da drinnen. So, jetzt haben wir ein neues Prometheus-Config, kann man Prometheus reloaden
oder kann man Prometheus nur restarten? Aha, man kann ein Postrequest an den Prometheus
Server schicken, dass er sich reloadet. Das ist doch sehr nice. Was machen wir noch?
Ok, dann machen wir das mit dem anderen, dann machen wir das hier. Wo läuft Prometheus
da? Hat er sich jetzt restartet? Hoffen wir mal. Handling for 5 minutes, sollte er da nicht
jetzt alerten so langsam? Ach, was auch immer. Wir schauen jetzt mal in unser Dashboard rein,
ob der jetzt schon erkannt hat, dass man Router da ist. Bäm, Mikrotik-Router, zack. Da du
ja Linux-Programmiest, wäre wichtig, dass das Wort Linux auch irgendwo im Titel steht.
Es ist keine schlechte Idee, tatsächlich nicht irgendein Schwachsinn im Titel zu schreiben,
sondern was ordentliches. Schreibe ich mir mal auf. Moonbear liest seine E-Mails in Emacs.
Ja ich muss sagen, an sich war ich lange Zeit, also ich verwende Wim ganz gerne einfach für
kleine Sachen, aber weil du es zackig aufmachen kannst, Kommandozahlen ist auf jedem System
traumhaft. Ich war lange Zeit recht, also am Anfang recht wimmfokussiert, danach fand
ich die ganze Zeit Emacs richtig toll. Einfach weil, also ich bin auch keiner, sagt das eine
ist besser als das andere. Einfach weil du das sau viel anpassen kannst, wie du willst
und dass es so Sachen wie Org Mode gibt. Mittlerweile, wahrscheinlich auch weil ich das jetzt auch
schon über 15 Jahre nähe, zumindest auf jeden Fall über 10 Jahre, den Kram schon mach 12
Jahre, 13, 15, lange, bin ich mittlerweile an dem Punkt angelangt, dass ich die Sachen
oftmals bevorzuge, die einfach funktionieren. Was in dem Fall weder Wim noch Emacs ist,
sondern z.B. ein GUI Notizprogramm, was mir das ganze auf meine Nextcloud züngt, anstatt
mit Org Mode rum zu wursten. Oder z.B. ein Caldav To Do Programm, was eben auch an meinen
Nextcloud sinken kann, ohne Org Mode in Emacs rumzukrebsen. Ja, aber es hat alle seine Vor-Nachteile.
Ja, Zellmore, genau, so macht das Wim. Das sucht sich auf der Zeile passend das nächste
aus mit CI Single Quartz. Also sprich, das nächste, wo das auftritt, springt da rein.
Guck mal, sogar der ganze Graph ist mittlerweile rot, weil es einen Alarm gibt. Ach guck mal,
er hat auch Notified. Cool, so. So, ok, jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, ob die Sache funktioniert
mit, dass er von meinem Router Stats abfragt. Ich lösche die Datei mal wieder auf meinem
Raspberry. Wie haustest du der Nextcloud? Also aktuell läuft das noch auf meinem Server,
der hier hinter mir im Rack steht. Auf dem laufen unterschiedliche Container, einer
davon ist Nextcloud. Wobei wir uns ja im Stream schon in einem der letzten Streams, und die
letzten Streams sind halt schon 3 Monate im Dezember, angeguckt haben, wie das in Zukunft
aussehen wird mit Netzwerkstruktur und Kisten bei mir daheim, weil die 4HE-Kiste, die da
aktuell drinnen hängt, kommt weg. Die wird ersetzt durch zwei kleine, tromsparende Vierkern,
das ist es nicht, Atom ist es nicht. Wie nennt man das? Gemini Lake heißt die Plattform
von Intel. Wer blickt bei Intel denn überhaupt noch durch, wie das Zeug heißt? Pentium Silver
heißen die Dinger jetzt. Warum auch immer, weil Intel, da habe ich schon die ganze Hardware
da. So, Datei weg, zack, Alert, wieder weg. Was für eine Router hast du? Ich hab mir
jetzt, also die ganze Zeit hatte ich ja noch meine PFSense laufen, aber mittlerweile bin
ich umgestiegen, wieder auf, wie gesagt, ich hab's ja gerade gesagt, mittlerweile mach
ich den Kram, es ist wahrscheinlich schon zu lang, dass ich versuche möglichst wenig
zu basteln, und das nehme, was quasi meine Vorstellung am ehesten entspricht, wo man
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was dran drehen muss und was einfach funktioniert. Als Router
hab ich stehen hier mittlerweile. Siehst du nun öfters? Ich kann nichts versprechen.
Ich hab ja im Dezember mich sau oft gestreamt und jetzt hatte ich irgendwie drei Monate
keinen Bock. Den hier hab ich aktuell. Ich muss mal Musik anmachen wieder.
So, den Router hab ich. Und das ist der Router, wo wir jetzt gerade Stats abfragen. Und wir
wollen jetzt mal gucken, ob das mit dem Stats abfragen überhaupt funktioniert. Add Query
Prometheus. Mikrotik. Mikrotik Interface Bites. Oder was gibt's denn da noch? Mikrotik, send,
receive. Ist da nicht irgendwie sowas wie total oder sowas? Okay, also was kann ich
von meinem Router abfragen? Uptime, Memory, Disk Space, Memory, CPU Load, Interface Error,
Interface Drop, Interface Packet. Machen wir einfach mal das da. Okay, das sind die
Werte von meinem Router aktuell. Interessant. Wieso arbeitest du in einer VM? Naja, das
ist halt Windows im Hintergrund noch läuft. Für PS und Games und Zeug. Es ist viel einfacher,
eine Linux VM auf Windows laufen zu lassen, wie Windows in der VM unter Linux. Deswegen
mache ich es so rum. Um fancy Netzwerkdiagramme zu machen. Also wenn wir irgendwas, also auf
der Arbeit, wenn wir irgendwas brauchen, wo man wirklich malen muss, dann nehme ich mittlerweile
eigentlich für alles Draw IO. Visio fasse ich nicht an. Draw IO ist ganz okay. Kann
man auch im Browser verwenden. Die haben auch schon Vorlagen für Netzwerk, Stells, Kram.
Kannst du hier auch, das ist ganz okay. Es ist ein bisschen lahmarschig, weil es halt
im Browser ist. Ansonsten versuche ich eigentlich so weit wie es geht, auf sowas zu verzichten.
Aber wenn es sein muss, dann Draw IO. Der kann kein VDSL wegdrehen. Das ist wirklich
nur ein Router. Das ist kein Fritzbox Ersatz, muss man auch dazu sagen. Das ist kein Fritzbox
Ersatz. Der ist ein Router und dafür ist er halt auch in dem, was er kann, nämlich Routen.
Richtig gut. Mit PoE drin, man hat noch einen SFP Port, falls man das braucht für halt
Module und Glasfaserkabel, wenn man das haben möchte. Ich brauch's an der Stelle nicht,
dafür hab ich den 10G Switch. Der ist nur zum Routen da. Und das ist halt dementsprechend
richtig gut. Der kann nämlich auch alles möglich. Also sprich, wenn man, also für Leute, die
es lernen wollen, kann ich das übrigens auch nur empfehlen, sich 1-2 MikroTik-Router zu
kaufen. Wer sich ein bisschen schlau machen will, was Routing-Protokolle angeht oder so,
ist das mit MikroTik wirklich schön zum Üben. Ja, wenn man sich die RouterOS Demo mal anguckt,
kann man ein bisschen mit rumspielen. So sieht die Oberfläche von jedem MikroTik-System
aus. Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht meine Oberfläche. Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht meine Oberfläche,
weil dann weiß ich nicht, ob ich die Details leake. Man kann alles machen, man kann wirklich
alles machen, was man sich so vorstellen kann, was IP und Routing-technisch aussieht bei
den MikroTik-Dingern. Und wenn jetzt jemand zum Beispiel sagt, er wollte schon immer
mal OSPF einrichten und ein bisschen damit rumspielen, ist das super, das mit MikroTik-Geräten
auszuprobieren. Man kann es natürlich auch virtuell simulieren, zum Beispiel bei Cisco,
da gibt es den Packet Tracer oder sowas, wo man dann auch schön nachgucken kann, wie
das funktioniert, wobei das halt rein simuliert ist und das ist halt echt. Und die Dinger
sind nicht teuer. So, ich wollte jetzt mal kurz gucken, was das exportiert hat. Also,
wir wollen jetzt da mal nachgucken, Interface. Ok, das ist die Übertragungsrate von meinem
Interface. Was irgendwie sich nicht aktualisiert, oder? Na doch. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Doch stimmt irgendwas nicht. Mach ich irgendwas falsch. Was? Fixed by ending rain? Ok, mache
ich. Ah! Moment, jetzt sieht das glaube ich auch gleich viel besser aus. Nö, auch ein
Shit. Ok, Moment, ich rück das jetzt mal hier ein. Als was arbeitest du und was machst
du da so? Das kann ich gleich was zu sagen. Ah, jetzt haben wir das, was mein Router überträgt.
Jetzt haben wir das. Sehr schön. So, Panel-Titel. Keine Ahnung, Router IO. Klasse Schick. Das
gefällt mir echt gut, die Geschichte hier. Also, da kann sich, also von der Einfachheit
halber kann sich der Zappix echt ein riesen Stück abschneiden. So, das ist das, was mir
hier gerade ein Router IO verursachen. Also, ich mein, der zeigt nur die Interfaces an,
die absint. Das kommt auch hin. Das ist cool. Das gefällt mir echt gut. Ja, genau. Als
was arbeitest du und was muss man da so machen? Also, da hatten wir es im Dezember schon öfters
begonnen und ich bin mittlerweile mal in mich gegangen und hab mir überlegt, ok, was auch
mit Bewerbungs-Sachen zu tun hatte. Wie gesagt, ich hab's euch am Dezember erzählt, ab 1.
2019 ist quasi die Frist abgelaufen, die mich daran gehindert hat, dass ich mir was
Neues suchen könnte, wenn ich will. Weil ich hab bei dem Laden, wo ich grad bin, die hatten
so eine betriebliche Altersvorsorge mit ziemlich guten Konditionen und die Sache ist, dass
du nur, das ist übrigens mittlerweile geändert, aber du musst eine gewisse Zeit dabei sein,
dass der Teil, den der Arbeitgeber einbezahlt hat, nicht mehr verfallen kann. Und das ist
bei mir ab 1.1.2019 gewesen. Deswegen hab ich auch letztes Jahr im Stream gesagt, wenn
ihr was Geiles Neues habt, sagt Bescheid. Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass ich was Neues
haben will, aber ich kann mir jetzt was Neues suchen. Ich hab auch schon ein bisschen geguckt
und was ich übrigens richtig krass fand, ich hab das ja im Stream gesagt, das letzte
Mal, im Dezember, mal ganz kurz, und ich hatte einen Tag später drei Angebote in der E-Mail.
Übels heftig. Hab ich gar nicht mit gerechnet, im Endeffekt. Hab ich gar nicht gedacht.
Einfach nur im Stream, wo ich mit 120 Leuten zuguck. Und der eine Laden war auch nur um
die Ecke bei uns. Zumindest hab ich jetzt mal Gedanken gemacht, wie das eigentlich
heißt, was ich mache. Und ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass ich Senior DevOps Engineer
bin. Ja, das mach ich. Und was ich wirklich mache ist, also das nennt man wirklich so,
wenn man mit der Zeit geht, passt das eigentlich am besten. Man kann sich da die besten Sachen
kreieren. Aber ich würde sagen, Senior DevOps Engineer trifft es eigentlich am besten.
Klingt vor allem auch gut. Und was ich wirklich mache ist, ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich
um die Quellcodeverwaltung bei uns auf der Arbeit und darum, dass wir regelmäßige Releases
haben von dem Produkt, was wir herstellen. Ich muss das immer versuchen, möglichst abstrakt
auszudrücken, dass ich da nicht aus Versehen irgendwas erzähle. Einmal im Monat eine neue
Version. Wir sind jetzt bei Version intern. Also wie ich das zähle, sind wir jetzt bei
Version 60 diesen Monat. Das heißt natürlich nicht 60. Das heißt, da kann man auch schon
erkennen, wenn das einmal pro Monat ist und Version 60 und ich mach das, ich hab mir das
Verfahren und das System ausgedacht, wie wir das machen, mach ich das auch schon eine Weile
in der Richtung. Und was das beinhaltet ist zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal den Sourcecode,
den Quellcodeverwaltungsteil anguckt, dass eigentlich hauptsächlich gucken, was es für
Änderungen gibt bzw. was Leute für neue Änderungen implementiert haben, mir das anzugucken, ob
das ordentlich getestet ist, ob das funktioniert, ob sich das vielleicht mit anderen Änderungen
nicht verträgt. Die Leute nerven, wenn sie in ihren Pull-Request Mist reingeschrieben
haben oder besser gesagt in den Merchrequest Mist reingeschrieben haben, dass das alles
schön beschrieben ist, dass ich da ein ordentliches Change-Log draus machen kann, weil im Vergleich
zu vielen anderen Produkten leg ich Wert darauf, dass wir ein ordentliches Change-Log haben,
wo man nachgucken kann, was sich geändert hat. Ja, da kann es natürlich sein, dass
sich irgendwelche Sachen nicht miteinander vertragen, da muss ich mir die zwei Leute
schnappen oder drei Leute schnappen und gucken, ok, deine Änderung verträgt sich nicht mit
der anderen, wie kann man das denn jetzt machen. Die ein oder anderen Sachen müssen natürlich
auch gottfixed werden, weil es kaputt ist und es erst auffällt, wenn das Ding schon
live ist. Und das ist eigentlich der hauptsächliche Teil. Und der zweite Teil ist zu gucken, dass
wir einmal im Monat ein neues Release rausbringen, was dann auch wiederum getestet werden muss,
das alte muss so lange betreut werden, bis das nächste da ist, muss mit hotfixes versorgt
werden, falls irgendwas kaputt ist und dementsprechend muss es natürlich auch mit Gott und der Welt
immer labern, wenn du irgendwie was Neues einspielen willst, weil ja irgendwie jeder
seinen Senf dazugeben muss, obwohl man Leute, die gar nicht eigentlich wissen, was damit
genau passiert, aber trotzdem müssen sie den Senf dazugeben. Achso, ja und sonst, das
ist eigentlich so ziemlich das, was den größten Teil meiner Zeit in Anspruch nimmt. Nebenbei
mache ich noch so Kleinkrams, zum Beispiel haben wir so eine Hostliste, bzw. was ist
eine Hostliste, so eine, nennen wir es mal Inventory, was ich gebastelt habe in Groovy
für unser Dokumentationssystem, wo man gucken kann, wo gerade welche Systeme laufen, weil
wir nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, mal ein ordentliches System einzuführen, was das speckt. Dann
habe ich in letzter Zeit ein bisschen versucht, einen Skype Chatbot zu programmieren, der
Leuten, die Fragen spezielle Informationen geben kann, so kam es. Also deswegen, nachdem
es so ein Zwischending ist zwischen eben Operation und Programmieren und Source Code Verwaltung,
trifft es eigentlich Senior DevOps Engineer am besten. So, jetzt habe ich euch lange genug
dazu geschwänzt. Den Befehl gibt es noch nicht. Sebaro, wenn es den Befehl nicht gibt,
du kannst einen Dings machen, du kannst einen Clip machen und kannst einen Command machen.
Du kannst einen Clip machen, du kannst den Clip verlinken. Wie gut muss man programmieren
können, um dort angestellt zu werden? Kommt drauf an, was für einen Bereich du machen
willst. Ja, so was in der Richtung. Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich muss erst mal gucken,
dass ich den Chat runterscrolle. Einmal so vier Tage die Woche, ja. Gab es schon Command?
Ja, Sebaro, mach einfach ein zweites, was passt. Oder überschreib das. Keine Ahnung. Mach
ein zweites. Kannste das erste noch einfügen. Wer noch mehr wissen will, gibt noch das
zweite Kommando ein. Ich wollte euch mal was zeigen, wo wir gerade dabei sind, was man
sich da für komische Dinge angucken muss, wenn man sowas macht. Ich poste ab und zu
mal. Also, wer ein bisschen Gelaber von mir auch über die Arbeit sehen will, der sollte
mir am besten auf Twitter folgen, da schreibe ich öfters mal was. Zum Beispiel solchen
Sachen muss man sich da auseinandersetzen. So, mit sowas zum Beispiel. Ich hab letztens
ein Archiv entpackt. Ich hab letztens ein Archiv entpackt bei uns. Und ich dachte ja,
ich hätte schon alles gesehen, ja. Ich dachte, ich hätte alle möglichen Sachen schon jemals
gerappt gesehen. Und solche Dinge, da greifst du dir halt auch immer an den Kopf, ne? Ich
mein, Deploy Assam, okay, verstehe ich noch. Ja. Deploy Rapper, so keine Ahnung. Irgendjemand,
also ich reime mir immer so Sachen zusammen, wie da Kram entsteht. Das war mal so das ursprüngliche.
Deploy Assam. Danach kam irgendjemand auf die Idee, dass nach dem Deployment auch eine
Slack-Nachricht verschickt werden soll zum Beispiel. Und er wollte allerdings das ursprüngliche
Skript nicht anwerfen, deswegen hat er hier eine Dreizeile reingeschrieben in Deployment
Rapper. Das heißt auch Deploy Rapper. Der Deploy aufruft und anhand des Return Codes
eine Slack-Nachricht schickt er nicht, okay. Achso, ja. Und dann gibt es Send Message,
die Deploy Rapper aufruft, um Slack-Nachrichten zu schicken. Dann gibt es eine Rapper Assam,
wo man anhand des Namens keinen Plastenschimmer hat, was sie ist. Eventuell noch mal ein Rapper
um den Rapper. Dann gibt es Rapper 2. Dann gibt es den Rapper für DB in Migrations,
der auf irgendwelche Gründe in Migrations rappen muss. Und dann gibt es das Highlight
und wo es echt aufgehört hat. Alter, das habe ich ja schon alles mehrfach gesehen hier
oben. Aber den Rapper Rapper, der hat wirklich alles getoppt bisher.
Ja, also was da alles gewrappt wird, das weiß keiner mehr. Das ist vorbei. Guck mal,
ob unser Router IO Graph funktioniert. ETH1 hat schwankende, schwankende Rate hier. Funktioniert.
Ich finde das richtig schön, dieses Grafana Dashboard. Das gefällt mir echt gut. Das
ist sehr, sehr nice. Sehr, sehr poggers. Nice, du auch noch. Moment, wo habe ich es
gesehen? Ich finde es gar nicht mehr. Jetzt habe ich irgendwas überlesen. Ja, also Sebaru
mit dem Command, kannst du es ruhig so machen. Also Ausrufe in Zeichen Arbeit ist gut. Das
kann man eigentlich so lassen. So, das kann man eigentlich so lassen. Du könntest noch
ein zweites Kommando machen, Ausrufe Zeichen Beruf oder so. Und du könntest dann jeweils
bei dem einen Kommando das andere Kommando noch dabei schreiben, so nach dem Motto, wer
noch mehr wissen will, macht halt Ausrufe Zeichen. Weil da kann ich auch drauf verweisen,
wer es wissen will, einfach Kommandos eingeben. Und da kann man als Clip, das was ich eben
erklärt habe, einschneiden. Ja, wenn das nicht passt mit dem Clip, erzähle ich es halt
noch mal kürzer. Oder einfach so weit wie es passt. Ach Katze, willst du jetzt raus?
Moment, ich muss die Katze rauslassen. Moment. So, Katze raus. Was das für eine Einheit
ist, ja das sollten wir vielleicht mal richtig einstellen. Die Einheit ist vermutlich mal
einfach Bites. Aber die Anzeige ist ein bisschen doof. Also hier sind Kilo Bites, aber der
unterliegende Wert wird wahrscheinlich in Bites sein. Deswegen können wir jetzt hier
einfach einstellen, dass die Unit ist Bites. Und schon funktioniert das auch richtig.
Jetzt haben wir hier nämlich auch die richtige Einheit, dass es Kilo Bites sind. Die unterliegende
Unit ist Bites, das ist okay. Und aktuell haben wir hier halt 623 Kilo Bites auf dem
Interface. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht was das ist. Ich muss mal gucken, auf was sich das
genau bezieht, was das eigentlich für ein Wert ist. Ja Bites, ja gut. Insgesamt kann
ich sein. Oder doch insgesamt? Ich weiß nicht. Ich bräuchte eigentlich sowas wie Sekunde
bräuchte man da. Muss ich mal schauen, wie man das am besten macht. Aber ich bin von
der Grafana Lösung wirklich echt begeistert, wie einfach das ist. Vor allem diese Alert-Geschichte
finde ich hier toll. Mach den Webpunkt mal wieder weg. Und also das funktioniert wirklich
viel einfacher, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Kein Vergleich zur ewigen Zabbix Template
Konfiguration. Und ich habe jetzt hier eine schöne Anzeige. Hier mache ich jetzt alle
meine Kisten rein. Da haben wir dann am Ende, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so bis hier gefüllt.
Nicht so, dass ich hier daheim irgendwie 50 Kisten stehen hätte oder so. Ist es theoretisch
möglich in Grafana auch Cloud-Speicherplatz anzuzahlen? Klar. Sofern du den Wert irgendwo
herkriegst, kannst du da alles rein passen. Rein, rein hauen. Ja, Zabbix hat seine Daseinsberechtigung,
keine Frage. Ich habe mir auch überlegt, ob ich mir nicht für daheim eine Zabbix hier
hinstelle. Aber ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock, mich großartig um Zabbix-Grams hier
daheim zu kümmern. Zabbix ist eine super Lösung, die alles vereint, was man so braucht.
Von Alerts bis aktive Checks, passive Checks, Graphen, Dashboards, Actions. Was hier Grafana
und Prometos glaube ich gar nicht können. Also sprich, in Zabbix kannst du ja zum Beispiel
auch einstellen, wenn der Festplattenplatz auf 10% fällt, dann zippe alle Locks. Das
ist so eine Action, die kann man im Zabbix einstellen. Das ist ganz cool. Zabbix hat
seine Daseinsberechtigung, aber für mein Mini-Monitoring, was ich daheim brauche. Es ist ja nicht so,
dass ich hier die klasse Business-Enterpreislösung brauche. Ist glaube ich die Kombination Prometos
und Grafana echt das beste, was geht. Vor allem das hier, das ist richtig gut. Du fügst
einfach die Kiste hinzu. Du hast standardmäßig schon einen Up-Down-Check. Ich habe hier meine
Raspberry-Festplattenplatz. Da kommen noch die anderen, kommen auch noch rein. Die anderen
zwei kommen auch noch rein. Dann sehe ich, wenn die Festplatte vom Raspberry vorläuft.
Die Router brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht. Habe ich jetzt nur zum Ausprobieren gemacht.
Ich habe die Einheit gerade eingestellt. Ja, Kilobein. Oder was meinst du? Na zumindest
wir können noch mal ausprobieren, ob er das jetzt checkt, wenn ich den Mikrotik. Wir können
das jetzt mal ausprobieren, was passiert. Ich kann jetzt meinen Router nicht ausschalten,
um zu gucken, was passiert. Das geht natürlich nicht. Aber ich kann den Mikrotik-Exporter
mal ausmachen. Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Zack, Pepehands. Kiste ist down.
So, und dann starten wir es wieder. Starten wir es wieder und dann sollte es gleich wieder
grün werden. Irgendwann, demnächst. Das ist, und wisst ihr was ich auch cool finde? Das
ist ultra, ultra schnell. Also ich meine, das braucht, keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden oder
10-15 Sekunden, bis der mitkriegt, dass was down ist. Ich meine, okay, das sind drei Hosts,
ja. Das ist kein Ding. Aber zum Beispiel Zappix-Intervall ist, glaube ich, standardmäßig 5 Minuten.
Oder 3 Minuten. 3 Minuten, oder? 305 Minuten ist, glaube ich, standardmäßig Zappix. Was
heißt, im Zappix kriegst du erst mal nur mit nach 3 Minuten, wenn irgendwas nicht da ist.
Kann man alles einstellen, ja. Aber das ist im Vergleich zu so einer klassischen Monitoring-Lösung
wie Zappix und Agri schon ziemlich schnell. Schreibe morgen eine Klausur in Java, mein
Beileid. Java-Klausur, da bin ich ja froh, dass ich darum umgekommen bin. Java ist geil,
deswegen heißt du auch Zagor.net, weil Java so geil ist. Also Leute, wir haben das geschafft,
was wir schaffen wollten, was für die Streams relativ selten ist. Normalerweise, ich meine,
es hat viel länger gedauert, als es sein muss, aber normalerweise wären wir in Streams selten
fertig mit dem, was wir machen wollten. Weil wir es zu Ende gemacht haben. So wirklich
zu Ende ist es nicht, aber so der Test, wie man es machen könnte, ist zu Ende. Und ich
muss sagen, ich finde das wirklich toll. Also das reicht für meine Zwecke daheim vollkommen
aus. Ich werde jetzt noch die, also ich werde jetzt erst mal von meinem Container runter
machen, das Prometos Ding und auf die richtige Kiste drauf ziehen. Aber es hat, Out of the
Box hat es jetzt eine Up-Down-Anzeige drin. Festplattenbelegung für den Raspberry, das
ist eigentlich die Hauptsache, warum ich es mache, dass das Ding nicht wieder voll läuft.
Ein bisschen Router-Statistik, die eigentlich kein Mensch braucht, die einfach nur drin
ist, weil es geht. Da habe ich schon mal das Wichtigste jetzt mit abgefangen. Und wenn
mal wieder irgendwas hier nicht funktioniert, gucke ich einfach rein, stelle fest, aha,
Festplatte voll. Oder im besten Fall kriege ich auch schon eine Message geschickt. Was
mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, ist, ob man mit Prometois Actions triggern kann.
Prometois AM Executor. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Wie würde man das denn machen? Also, was
ich mir gerade überlege ist, mit Samex zum Beispiel oder Nagios auch. Wobei Nagios habe
schon ganz lange nichts mehr gemacht. Ist es so, man kann, also in Topics ist es quasi
schon eingebaut, man kann zum Beispiel sagen, wenn ein Fehler auftritt, dann löse folgende
Aktion aus. Also du hast zwei Sachen. Wenn ein Fehler aufdrückt, dann schick eine Nachricht
und du kannst aber auch noch zusätzlich sagen, wenn ein Fehler auftritt, schick eine Nachricht
und versuche den Fehler zu lösen. Also quasi, dass man den Skript hinterlegt oder was,
was er machen soll. Zum Beispiel, wenn dein Web-Server abgestürzt ist, schickst du eine
Nachricht, hallo, Web-Server ist abgestürzt und danach führst du eine Aktion aus, System
CCL, Restart, HTTPD. Das kannst du in Submix einstellen. Ich frage mich, ob sowas auch
mit Prometois möglich ist oder mit Grafana. Wobei ich Grafana nicht so darin sehe, weil
Grafana ist im Prinzip das Frontend und sonst nichts. Mit Delphi im Jahr 2019. Das ist aber
auch noch mal so ganz aktuell. Also anscheinend bin ich der Einzige, der so eine Idee hat,
das hier scheint er sowas zu machen. Execute Command Based on Prometois Alerts. Sollte
man wohl mit einer Message queue machen. Ja, ich frage mich halt, ob es was gibt, was schon
fertig ist. Was übrigens sehr cool ist, weil ich letztens gefunden habe eine Seite, ich
muss mal schauen, ob ich die jetzt wieder finde, weil dieses ganze Thema Server Monitoring,
Performance Monitoring, System Monitoring, Metriken sammeln, Performance Analyse. Das
ist mittlerweile ein sehr unübersichtliches Feld, was es da alles für Tools gibt. Und
ich habe zwei Seiten gefunden, die einem da ganz gut helfen können bei. Einmal das da
und das da. Wobei ich frage, wo die Seite ist, wo ich das gefunden habe. Ja, über Alerts
funktioniert es. Die Frage ist nur, wer es dann ausführt. Ich könnte natürlich einen
Alert nehmen, der einen Webhook triggert, bei meinem Problem Fix Dienst. Und der dann
die Probleme versucht zu fixen. Aber da weiß ich halt nicht, was es da so gibt. Also ich
habe letztens eine Seite gefunden, wo halt genau dieses Bild. Ach hier. Das ist doch
das da, ist es genau. Nee. Nein, es ist nicht. Zumindest, ich habe die Seite letztens gefunden,
wo dieses Bild hier halt herkommt. Und das fand ich, ist echt eine ganz gute Hilfe gewesen.
Was es so für Monitoring Tools gibt. Da ist nämlich der ganze Mist mal zusammengefasst
und was ich auch ganz cool finde, ist die Seite, da kann man sein Monitoring System auswählen
und das zeigt dir dann quasi an, was mit wem irgendwie zusammenpasst. Und man sieht schon,
es ist relativ unübersichtlich, was es so für Monitoring Geschichten mittlerweile
alles gibt. Jetzt wenn ich mir so recht überlege, so diese Geschichte mit Actions ausführen,
wenn was kaputt ist, könnte man auch relativ simpel selbst irgendwas bauen eigentlich.
Man macht einen Alert mit sagen wir einem Webhook und dann hängt man einfach irgendwo
was dahinter, halt was einen Port aufmacht, wo halt auf Webhooks hört und der sich dann
per SSH auf Systeme einloggt und was ausführt. Wobei es halt doof ist, dann müsste dieses
System wieder SSH Zugang haben. Es wäre halt viel schöner, wenn man das über den Agent
machen könnte. Da muss ich mal gucken, ob es sowas gibt. Weil es wäre cool, wenn man
beispielsweise über diesen Prometheus Exporter oder so einfach Skript ausführen könnte.
Aber dafür ist er wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht. Sonst müsste man wieder SSH Keys verteilen.
Da muss es irgendwas Fertiges geben. Und was jetzt ja komplett nicht zielführend wäre,
ist, sich dafür einen Subbix zu installieren. Dann hast du ein super einfaches Monitor
mit Prometheus und Grafana und dann hängst du auf den Subbix hinten dran. Das ist ja
auch nicht so ein Zweck der Übung. Da muss ich mal nachher ein bisschen GitHub durchsuchen.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal was futtern gehen. Da muss ich mal nachher ein bisschen GitHub
durchsuchen, was es da gibt. Ich könnte wetten, da gibt es schon was. Plus, dass man immer
erst mal gucken muss, nach was für tollen Buzzwords man da suchen muss. Die werden nicht
einfach in die Beschreibung schreiben, so nach dem Motto, ist ein Programm, was auf
anderen Servern Befehle ausführen kann. Nein, nein, das nennt sich dann wahrscheinlich
Ops Orchestrating Performance Optimization Command Executor oder sowas. Die müssen ja
immer besonders krass heißen. Die heißen nicht einfach Befehle ausführer oder so.
Ne Sebao, das war es nicht. Ich glaube, die haben das nur gehyjacked, so ein bisschen
das Bild. Das hat irgendein anderer Typ erstellt. Guck mal, der Eaxe ist da. Eaxe, du hast
immer noch deinen Apex-Name. Spielst du noch Apex? Ich habe das Gefühl, der Apex-Hype
ist ein bisschen vorbei. Guck, die schreiben mir das gleiche, was ich auch schon gesagt
habe. Einfach den Web-Server dranhängen, der den Webhook abfängt. Da gibt es bestimmt
was Fertiges. Gut, Leute, ich bin fertig. Ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich hoffe, euch
hat der Stream gefallen. Tatsächlich, mehr Probleme als zum Release. Ich sehe auch die
Viewer-Zahlen auf Twitch, was Apex angeht. Am Anfang, als Apex rausgekommen ist, hat
es ja die Sache hier so 50-50 fast Fortnite Apex. Overwatch komplett am Arsch der Welt
gewesen. Teilweise sogar ein bisschen mehr Apex als Fortnite. Mittlerweile hast du wieder
die üblichen Verdächtigen. Vorne LoL und Fortnite. Wobei Fortnite mittlerweile wieder
hinter LoL ist, was ich auch Apex, PUBG, was in Asien total abgeht, und Firestorm und
viele andere Konkurrenzdinger noch ein bisschen zuschreibe. Aber wenn man sich das hier mal
anschaut, es ist im Vergleich zu letzter Zeit doch schon ganz schön abgefallen. Twitch
Lightdesigner, ich habe hier nie Twitch auf. Wo ich gucke, habe ich selbstverständlich
Dark Steam. Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Follows. Ich gucke mal nach. Ganz, ganz vergessen.
Was habe ich da für ein Service-Shirt verwendet? Steamlabs. Solange ich schon einmal gestreamt
habe, ich kann gar nicht mehr weiß, wo ich nachgucken kann. Okay, ich gucke jetzt mal
die Follows. Ich sehe leider nicht alle. Nach welchem System das hier was anzeigt, habe
ich auch noch nicht so genau kapiert. Ich sehe immer nur die letzten. Danke für die
Follows. Darlump79, CaptainMax, Zagor.net, Figo, Happy Ante, Newton314 und TrueYagami.
Vielleicht waren das alle, vielleicht habe ich noch welche vergessen. Wie gesagt, mehr
sehe ich leider nicht mehr hier. Kommt noch eine Showtour mit dem Friseur? Ne. Ich glaube,
also an mir liegt es nicht. Aber ich glaube, da fahren wir an Wille nicht. Ich, ähm, wo
wir gerade bei MMOs sind, ich bin gerade wieder hängen geblieben bei, oh fuck, ich habe den
Chat reloaded. Also falls einer was geschrieben hat, was ich noch nicht beantwortet habe,
müsste ich das ja nochmal schreiben. Ich habe gerade auch so den reloaded. Ich bin hier
gerade hängen geblieben. Da. PlayPhoenix, das ist ein Dark Age of Camelot-Free-Shirt.
Mit relativ vielen Spielern drauf für den Free-Shirt und mit super Custom-Anpassungen,
aber das ist glaube ich nichts für Leute, die es früher nie gespielt haben, weil das
Game ist fast 20 Jahre alt. Was für Programmiersprachen verwendest du und magst du so? Wie gesagt,
ich muss gleich fortangehen, das ist das letzte, wo ich jetzt, oder was, was ich jetzt noch
beantworten kann. Ähm, meine Lieblingssprache, hättest du mich das vor ein paar Jahren gefragt,
hätte ich gesagt, so eine Mischung aus C-Sharp und Ruby. Mittlerweile verwende ich kaum
noch Ruby, allerdings wieder viel mehr C-Sharp. Also meine absolute Lieblingssprache eigentlich
seit immer schon ist C-Sharp und das, obwohl ich eigentlich hauptsächlich unter Linux
unterwegs bin, mit Linux mein Geld verdiene und mich mit Windows relativ wenig auskenne
über das, was als Anwender eben hinausgeht. Trotzdem finde ich es dort nett und C-Sharp
immer noch die angenehmste Umgebung und die schönste Sprache, sowohl zum Einstieg als
auch für alles andere. Gefällt mir am besten. Das einzige, wo es ein bisschen hinten runter
fällt, ist Cross-Platform, GUI-Programme, kannst du damit im Endeffekt nicken, mal gucken,
was da in Zukunft so kommt. Guck dir mal Kotlin, dann hab ich mir schon angeguckt. Wenn ich
nicht drumherum komme, mach ich was auf der Java-VM, aber ich komm zum Glück immer drumherum.
Das heißt, ich mach eigentlich nichts, was sich irgendwie mit Java zu tun hat, beziehungsweise
mit, ich weiß, dass das nicht mit der Programmiersprache zu tun hat, aber ich vermeide alles, was
auf der Java-Runtime irgendwie basiert. Ich will damit eigentlich gar nichts großartig
zu tun haben. Mir ist auch klar, dass dort nett im Prinzip nicht viel anders ist, unten
drunter, aber ich mag dort nett einfach deutlich mehr. Genau, also meine Abstandlieblingssprache
ist die Sharp, gefolgt von Ruby, wobei ich in Ruby relativ wenig mache. Was ich in letzter
Zeit auch relativ häufig benutzt habe, auch hier im Stream halt wegen Webzeugen, ist JavaScript,
auch wenn ich JavaScript ziemlich hässlich finde. Eine richtig schöne neue Programmiersprache,
wenn man drauf steht, dass die Programmiersprache einen abfuckt, im positiven Sinne, weil das,
was rauskommt eigentlich besser ist, ist Rust. Also wer mal wirklich sich, wenn man richtig
kotzen will beim Programmieren, der lernt Rust. Der Borrow-Checker wird euch so abfucken
bei Rust, wenn ihr damit anfangt. Aber an sich sorgt es eigentlich dafür, dass der
Programmfluss keine kritischen Fehler haben kann. Also was nicht heißt, dass Rust immer
das macht, was ihr wollt, aber ihr könnt nicht aus Versehen irgendwo was belegen und
nie wieder freigeben oder nicht aus Versehen in einem Toilett was bearbeiten, was ein anderer
gerade verwendet und sowas. Also Rust kann man empfehlen, sich das anzugucken. Ruby on
Rails gefällt mir auch persönlich ziemlich gut. Das war so der Grund, warum ich damals
mit Ruby angefangen habe vor einer ganzen Weile. Vor Rails 2, das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her. Damals habe ich viel Ruby Zeug gemacht. Eine Sprache, die ich natürlich auch täglich
verwenden muss, weil Linux ist Shell in irgendwelchen Ausprägungen. Die meisten Leute sagen Bash,
aber eigentlich ist es in allen möglichen Shells lauffähig. Also Linux Shellscripting
kommste eigentlich nicht drum herum. Ein bisschen was in Groovy mache ich ab und zu. Ich weiß,
das ist auch Java, aber da komme ich nicht drum herum, weil das System, wofür das Plugin
ist, halt auf Java Basis läuft. Und da war Groovy die damals am wenigsten nervige Sprache
für. An der Python mache ich kaum was. Ich kann das lesen und finde das eigentlich auch
keine schlechte Sprache. Vor allem im wissenschaftlichen Bereich ist das mittlerweile ziemlich etabliert.
Im Machine Learning Bereich ist es mittlerweile auch ziemlich stark dabei, wenn man sich
die TensorFlow anguckt und dieses... Kennt ihr das? Dieses Person is not real von NVIDIA?
Das ist glaube ich mit TensorFlow gemacht. Hab ich euch... Kennt ihr das schon?
Nee, nicht Weep. Aber doch, nach Weep suche ich jetzt mal. Und zwar, das Ganze gibt es
nämlich auch in der Weep-Variante.
Okay, aber gucken wir uns mal das Original an. Person not real. Zeige ich euch jetzt
gleich einmal. Das ist ein Gesichtsgenerator. Ich muss jetzt erstmal ausprobieren, ob das
die richtige Uhr ist. Die kann ich euch jetzt hier erstmal nicht zeigen. Nicht, dass das
jetzt irgendwie auf irgendeine Porn-Seite geht oder so. Nee, genau, das ist die richtige
Uhr. Das ist von NVIDIA ein Gesichtsgenerator auf, ich glaube TensorFlow, Machine Learning
Basis.
Okay, der funktioniert unter Linux und Firefox anscheinend nicht. Chrome?
Okay, dann wechseln wir mal auf Windows. So, das ist ein Gesichtsgenerator. Die Leute
gibt es nicht. Die Gesichter werden bei jedem Aufruf neu generiert.
Okay, was auch immer. Irgendwie ist es kaputt. Aber ihr könnt es mal ausprobieren. Das wird
bei jedem Aufruf neu generiert. Und du kannst die Sachen wirklich sehr schwer noch von echten
Personen unterscheiden. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Seite gerade rumspackt. Aber ihr habt
es ja gerade gesehen. Ihr könnt das mal ausprobieren, das ist wirklich ziemlich gut gemacht.
Achso, und dann hätte ich noch was für unsere ganzen... Ja, ich habe die Seite wieder gefunden.
So, und dann hätte ich noch was für die Weebs unter uns. Das Ganze gibt es natürlich auch.
Das gibt es natürlich auch den Wifu Generator. Das ist quasi die gleiche Library unten drunter.
Die gleiche TensorFlow, das ist das auch Python Zeug. Da ist die gleiche Library unten drunter
wie diese PersonNotReal. Bloß, dass sie Anime-Mädels generiert. Und wie gesagt, man sieht es ja
auch hier an den Ansätzen. Das ist schon ein bisschen kaputt. Aber das ist halt alles
quasi KI generiert. Das ist schon beeindruckend, was da mittlerweile geht. Leider geht irgendwie
die... Ach, jetzt geht es wieder. Man sieht schon, dass das hier teilweise ein bisschen
komisch aussieht. Aber die Leute sind halt alle quasi aus dem Generator rausgefallen,
den sie trainiert haben mit ganz vielen Bildern. Und du kannst es nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Zu 90% kannst du es nicht unterscheiden. Hier jetzt schon, aber du hast so ganz... Ich glaube,
die haben irgendwie ein Rate-Limit oder sowas drin, dass es nicht funktioniert. Naja, gut,
das habe ich euch mal gezeigt. Und ja, wo wir... Da sind wir draufgekommen beim Thema Python.
Das ist TensorFlow drunter. Das ist Python. Ja, also in diesem Bereich ist das... Ruf das mit
slash image auf, okay. Ach, geht das dann? Ah, interessant. Guck mal, das ist so mit... Da
erkennst du keinen unter... Da erkennst du nicht, dass es... Hier nebendran vielleicht, aber du
erkennst nicht, dass die Gesichter generiert sind. Das sieht echt aus. Plus, dass es die Leute
halt alle nicht gibt. Das ist jetzt halt ein bisschen failgeneriert, ja. Und jetzt alle nicht.
Und die sind mittlerweile in diesem Bereich schon wirklich weit, ja. Also es ist echt beeindruckend,
was sie da mit hinkriegen. Wobei wahrscheinlich für euch der WIFO-Generator wieder viel
interessanter ist. Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Programm zufällig eine Person generiert,
die exakt so aussieht wie du? Kann man schlecht sagen, ohne dass man den Generator kennt,
wieder funktioniert. Ich würde mal sagen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ziemlich gering.
Aber ich finde es cool. Ich hatte gerade zweimal dasselbe Bild, jetzt kann es sein, dass sie das
irgendwie cashen. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie das jedes Mal neu berechnen. Die werden
generieren und generieren und dann haben sie so einen Pool, den sie am Tag anzeigen oder so. Aber
das ist schon nicht schlecht. Ja, so, Programmiersprachen, was haben wir sonst noch? Irgendwas vergessen?
Ja, das waren eigentlich so meine Favoriten. Koboll natürlich, davon nicht vergessen.
Und so Ausgeburten wie Emacs, Lisp fangen wir jetzt mal gar nicht an, weil da musste...
Ja, das ist einfach nicht schön. Ansonsten gibt es eigentlich... Ja, um an Microsoft zu loben,
an sich ist PowerShell nicht schlecht. Auch wenn ich damit wenig mache, aber an sich ist
PowerShell echt nicht übel. Schau mal C++ Programmier, ja leider, leider. Da kann ich
nur mal auf meinen Twitter-Account verweisen. Da fällt mir nämlich auch gerade wieder ein,
dass ich letztens was zu C++ gepostet habe, weil das C++ ja eine so furchtbar schöne
Programmiersprache ist. Ich meine, wer hat sich denn diese Lambda-Syntax ausgedacht hier,
was ist das denn? Dann soll man es wenigstens ausschreiben, wie sie das in Ruby machen,
oder ich glaube in Python auch ausschreiben. Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht? Weißt du,
die haben sich überlegt, so nach dem Motto, okay, wir wollen eine Lambda-Syntax machen,
lass uns mal bitte Zeichen verwenden, die schon fünffach mehrfach Bedeutung in C++ haben.
Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee, die nehmen wir. Wir nehmen unbedingt, wir müssen unbedingt eckige
Klammer nehmen und am besten, am besten auch noch Sternchen, am besten noch ein und und dann
auch noch Komma und ja. Also das sieht wirklich zum Kotzen aus. Und das hier ist, das ist Welle
C++-Syntax. Das ist nicht so, dass ich mir das einfach ausgedacht habe. Also nein, Schwachsinn.
Also ich habe mir das natürlich ausgedacht, dieses Beispiel, aber das ist Welle C++-Syntax. Das ist
okay, das geht so. Wenn du das Syntax checken lässt, wenn es die ganzen Sachen gibt, geht das. Und
das ist halt der Witz. Ich meine, das ist quasi ein Modul oder wie er, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie es bei C++ genau heißt. Und da drin eine Klasse und davon mit dem Generic-Type so,
der im Konstruktor eine Funktion oder eine Lambda übergeben kriegt, der glaube ich alle,
fuck wie ist das, alle umliegenden Variablen, Captured als Referenz. Das hier funktioniert
übrigens nicht. Da dürfte glaube ich nur das drinne stehen. Und dann da drinne quasi die Funktion
hässliche Sprache aufrufen. Go finde ich auch keine schöne Sprache. Go hat seine Daseinsberechtigung,
Go hat viele nette Features. Zum Beispiel, dass sie eben Binary's generieren, die eben einfach
funktionieren, ohne dass man Zeug installieren muss. Das ist meiner Meinung nach der größte Vorteil
von Go. Ich finde sowohl von der Syntax, von der Handhabung her auch, finde ich Go nicht so schön.
Mich nervt schon das hier immer so. Aber okay, ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung von Go.
Aber das war's zur Ansprache. So Leute, ich muss jetzt was futtern. Mal an der Stelle Schluss.
Kannst den Kram mal ausmachen hier, zack, zack. Oh nee, Moment. Das machen wir jetzt nicht. Wenn
ich das jetzt mache, dann kill ich wieder meinen Raspberry. Power off. Übrigens, das würde ich
euch empfehlen, auf jedem System zu installieren, was ihr selbst administriert. Das alias Power off
und Shutdown und sowas. Und ihr müsst zur Bestätigung nochmal den Systemname eingeben,
dass das macht. Immer, immer draufhauen. So, wunderbar. Wir haben's geschafft. Leute,
macht's gut. Wir sehen uns das nächste Mal. Und jetzt muss ich noch meine Outro-Musik anmachen.
Bis dann, macht's gut. Tschüss.